e
well good morning to everybody and thank
you for those who made the effort to get
here um the hearings this is all
hearings today there's no executing of
bills uh the first one is here at 9:30
and we'll we'll go ahead with that it's
HB
659 establishing New Hampshire college
graduate retention incentive program and
I'd like to welcome represent man high
here
nope okay and there's no other sponsors
on that bill would we have somebody like
to go just introduce to Bill Forest to
say I'm here to introd I'm I'm behalf of
this person I'm interested in the bill
we've done that
before reps and fellas you're do it
also
a thank you Mr chair um on behalf of the
sponsors and co-sponsors who are not um
present at the moment I introduce hb6 59
establishing the New Hampshire college
graduate retention incentive program
thank you okay we'll we'll need a pink
card though just to verify that you
introduced it represent
fellows got it okay are there any other
people want to testify on that bill or
provide technical support
Dr welcome it's Lauren yes yes Lauren
welcome
are you going to be addressing the
fiscal
much have a copy good morning for the
record my name is Lauren O Sullivan and
I am the senior Financial Analyst at the
Department of Revenue Administration and
I'm here today to just speak on some of
the technical aspects of the bill as a
Rel relates to the uh the BET rebate and
for that so the first thing that um what
I've handed out is our fiscal note quick
guide I believe this was emailed out
also either on Monday or Tuesday
morning did
you to whom um it was sent out to um the
committee did you not rece if you did
not receive the email while apologize
and we'll just double check that we have
the correct email address for the
committee yeah I just had a whole back
and forth with is it Miss Ramsey yes
this week and she assured me that I'd
have them the day before okay they were
sent out earlier this week so we'll
double check that and I can also speak
with um with the uh with Jennifer 4 to
make sure the had got out thank you
welcome yes just to clarify so is corre
one dat January 30th as far as I know
that's correct so what I've provided is
um a fiscal note quick guide which just
essentially um elaborates on on the
portion that the Department of Revenue
had written I we take one pass around
yeah let me ask a question here does
everybody have the January pardon
30 okay it's making its way around sorry
um so all all this really is it's a
courtesy it just elaborates on um dr's
contribution to the fiscal
note because especially when there's
multiple agencies that are contacted to
provide information that there's a
summarize does everybody also have the
January
30th Amendment or fiscal note excuse me
Fiscal note if not we can get some
copies
made pardon
me well it's and it's an updated one
there was an initially a fiscal note
dated January uary
13th me okay yeah okay good we're ready
to go okay okay sorry about that um so
um the first thing I just want to just
discuss um our understanding that this
is um for the portion as it relates to
the business hiring incentive program
that um this is a rebate as opposed to a
credit against the business Enterprise
tax so really um our our question to
this is this program intended to be a
rebate or a credit and how would that
work so a rebate um when the Dr
administers a rebate taxpayers submit a
claim and attach appropriate
documentation to demonstrate they are
eligible which can include proof of
payment or of a tax liability once
approved they receive a check from the
state so a rebate program that we
administer would be something like the
low and moderate uh homeowners property
tax relief program whereas a credit when
we administer a credit taxpayers submit
an application and attach appropriate
docu documentation and once approved
receive a letter confirming their
eligibility and the amount of credit
that can be claimed they then claim the
credit on the appal applicable tax
return and an example of that would be
the research and development tax
credit and then both a rebate anacredit
program can be capped it was we we are
assuming in this bill that there is no
cap on the
rebate um and when there is a cap on any
of these programs eligibility is
typically determined first and then when
the application period or program year
closes the amount of credit or rebate is
determined based upon the cap and then
in these cases the taxpayer receives two
letters and some programs are
administered first come first serve and
some are administered so that
distribution of funds or credits are
done on a pra basis
so that's where we were just looking for
some clarity in the language of the bill
and then also an additional issue for
credit programs is on what return or
Returns the credit can be claimed for
some programs the credit is only claimed
in the year after issuance if a
taxpayer's tax liability is less than
the amount of the credit that can be
claimed the remaining credit is not used
for other programs the credit can be
carried forward for some number of years
and some credits may even be
transferable between taxpayers or
between taxes so it was also we assumed
while reading the proposed legislation
that um this rebate would not carry
forward so then if someone is awarded
more rebate then they have liability
they would not receive all of it and
then um we all are also making an
assumption that um the Department of
Business and economics Affairs is the
one that is administering the
rebate and that it's not the Dr it was
not clear in the legislation who the
department was in that section of the
bill and
then and then also we are also making an
assumption that this part of the program
is effective for tax years beginning on
or after December 31st
2025 but um with that that is a an
assumption that we do suggest some
clarifying language for Which tax years
the rebate has become effective for
administration and um if there are and
then also just one thing I want to note
for those who aren't familiar with the
business Enterprise tax credit against
the business profits tax um any program
that reduces the BET then also reduces
the credit to the business profits tax
so if a taxpayer has liability for both
taxes a decrease in bet can
theoretically be an increase in the
business profits tax but that's only in
those cases where the taxpayer has
liability for both taxes so for those
who aren't aware I'd let you
know okay um any questions thank you
very much for giving us some of your
concerns and issues associated with this
interpretation are there any questions
Dr yes represent Damon thank you Mr
chair I actually just want to ask you to
re repeat what you just stated about the
impact on BET from a BPT correct sure so
any I'll actually read this word for
word and this is also in the quick guide
and I think it's also in the fiscal note
too in case you didn't capture at all
any program reducing bet will also
reduce the BET credit available to
offset the business profits tax there by
increasing the business profits tax
revenue however the BBT increase will be
less than the BET decrease because not
all taxpayers have a business pro uh
profits tax liability to be offset by
the BET credit and that all taxpayers
bet liability exceeds the BBT Credit in
those situations the BET loss and
revenue is not fully offset by an
increase in business profits tax
liability
does that does that help answer your
question it will when I read it again
thank you okay Bas essentially they're
not it's not one for
one yes represent papovich thank you
just a very brief question billing on
what you said and if you have the answer
off the C great if not no stress but in
that situation where the impact is
maximized right the reduction in the the
rebate towards the BET then Ates the
maximum amount of BPT possible what
would be that ratio so for every $100 in
a bet credit what's the most we would
ever get under the most Rosy scenario in
B
PT so um so let's say before the rebate
or the credit if someone has $100 in bet
liability and $200 in BBT liability the
BET credit against the BBT would reduce
that 200 by the
$100 however if someone had let's say
it's the other way and they have $50 in
BBT liability only $50 of that bet
liability can offset that but then
there's um a carry forward provision
where um the next year if um that credit
can roll forward and be used against the
next tax Year's BBT
liability thank you as a former CPA I
love those levels of details so thank
you no problem further questions from
the
committee what do you expect the would
be the cost for administering this
program by the Department of Business
and economic Affairs um is that cost
included in this dollar amount we're
we're seeing here um I cannot speak to
what business and economic Affairs has
written what their cost to administer
the program would be but um for for the
Dr in order to um update any necessary
tax form forms or electronic Management
Systems we have the rim system or any
Communications to taxpayers that can be
absorbed in the our current budget and
with our current Staffing it can be abor
absorbed into current Staffing
yep see in dbea they're saying they need
additional Staffing to do this well
that's well that is um the question is
who's administering it but just for us
updating our tax forms and letting our
Granite tax connect system accept that
information when we're determining the
tax liability that the Dr can absorb
that thank you I can't speak on behalf
of that agency
yes further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much well thank you have a good day yeah
snow um are there any other folks that
would want to speak to this bill it's HB
me
yes yes you you can speak if you fill
card are there any
more guys some there was a stack of them
right yeah they came around I think they
direction
yes that it doesn't include the cost
remember if it's not ready we don't we
we won't have the time to fix it if it's
really
broken
you got one pink coming at you here she
floor that's something aen graduate
[Laughter]
we got it
a
okay okay Andrew horn you're welcome to
welcome you need to push the button and
the red light will come out there you go
okay
nice okay is
that okay all right clear yeah okay
thank you so much for um giving me the
opportunity to speak uh Mr chairman uh
members of the committee um
unfortunately Sanji benart would would
would you please say your name and where
you're from and then because it's on the
card but we have to put it in the record
understood so my name is Andrew horn I'm
from Amhurst New Hampshire thank you no
worries so so um uh unfortunately the
primary sponsor on this pill San sanie
manahar was um in a a freak accident a
few weeks ago so he wasn't able to uh
attend this hearing um I only found out
of this hearing this morning so I just
rushed in uh from Amherst um uh I I kind
of was there uh this build wasn't my
idea but I was kind of there as he was
um developing it uh I um I was a field
organizer with the New Hampshire uh
Democratic party and I helped him get
elected which is why like we have that
relationship so um one of the things
that this bill is trying to solve is
that we have a huge outflow of young
people uh once they graduate from
college um so 48 to 56% of graduates
leave the state after graduation and in
the state of New Hampshire our our
largest demographic growth is in
seniors um just people aging uh in the
state people leave because there are um
more economic opportunities outside the
state whether it be Massachusetts or
other states and people don't generally
come back um New Hampshire is actually
the number one state in the country for
graduates leaving the state after
graduation so this bill is trying to you
know take a bite out of that problem
trying to incentivize people to stay
here after the graduate and trying to
incentivize businesses to hire people um
and with a pretty strong incentive to
hire uh
interns
um and sji wanted to mention how uh the
people who do come to this state tend to
be people who are coming here safe for
Massachusetts because say the nsha
housing prices are a little bit lower so
it drives up the housing prices um
so we really need to keep that talent
that young talent in the state um we
don't have that uh right now again we
are the number one state for graduates
leaving and and this seeks to uh respond
to that problem
questions you you finished I am finished
okay thank you very much other questions
from the committee represent pap
thank you Mr chair and thank you for the
effort of coming in on short notice and
letting us know what's going on no
reason um you were quoting a 48 to 56%
of graduate living the state yes is that
New Hampshire residents who are college
graduates or all college graduates that
graduate from New Hampshire colleges I
I'm sorry I uh I you would have to ask
Sanji if um no worry I was just curious
if if I any chance you knew I I
appreciate it that's all I had thank you
further questions yes represent
Damon thank you for being here thank you
Mr chair um
so it speaks about a $5,000 annual
student loan
forgiveness to graduates who commit to a
minimum of three consecutive years of
employment within the state and then
says the total forgiveness amount shall
not exceed $20,000 per
individual
awarding
$20,000 and The Graduate might only stay
three years I feel like there's a $5,000
discrepancy there yeah um now that you
pointed out I do find that interesting
um I mean
uh I let me tell you I've talked to OS
they they're crazy busy all the time
it's possible it's it's their oversight
it's possible that uh it's s ch's
oversight um uh let me tell you in terms
of the details I'm sure sanie would uh
would work with you in terms of like you
know the the core goal is what he wants
preserved you know incentivizing uh
graduates to stay in the state um not
specific details thank you f further
questions from the committee yes
representative fellows thank you um I I
don't mean to put you on the spot it's
okay um did did you have any discussions
or do any research on where the the the
graduates go that don't stay in New
Hampshire
and right um so as I said my uh
understanding is is a little bit surface
level right now but I believe most of
them go to Massachusetts you
know yes and do you have any idea why
they go would go to Massachusetts yeah
Economic Opportunity there are more jobs
there okay maybe sorry eom yeah economic
such as followup paron me followup one
more sure go ahead economic such as the
salary they could earn
yes further questions from the
committee not seeing anything oh yes
represent
Brown thanks for
coming so the um the bill mentions
education is one of the eligible High
need fields
um but then later on in the the bill it
states that this is mainly targeted to
businesses small and mediumsized
businesses but in most towns the school
district is the largest
employer um so I'm just wondering would
a public school be eligible to
included um again I think that this is
something that uh
can you can you specify where in the
definitions uh the first
page eligible High eligible High need
Fields means occupations in Health Care
Child Care elder
care and then at the end it says and
education
and education and then the small and
mediumsized businesses I know i' I've
read that do you remember where that is
bill
uh sorry that's
uh
I
see it says priority so I'm not
sure it it uh stops um you know
education from being
incentivized i i in terms of his
intention I can't say specifically um
when I talked to him about it he didn't
talk about this like specifically I'm
sure that he would be uh more than
willing to adapt some kind of language
that would clarify um what kind of uh
businesses are
eligible for further questions from the
committee yes representa
Damon thank you again Mr chair um so it
references seeking other funding
opportun Federal funding opportunities
including grants under the workforce
Innovation and Opportunity Act which I
am not familiar with can do you have any
um I'm sorry can you specify the
um well let's see it sounds like you
don't have the same copy we have yeah
it's Roman numeral 4 on my page
to oh I see the workforce Innovation and
Opportunity
Act I don't know about it I'm sure he
can speak to
it represent kcom thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for taking my question can you
just clarify I don't know if I heard you
correctly before did you say you were
going to contact o about something can
you just explain what you were going to
contact OSS about no I'm not going to
contact OS I was just surmising why
there was a discrepancy between um the
5,000 per year uh loan forgiveness and
the total of $20,000 per individual that
there was a discrepancy because you
would expect it to be $15,000 per
individual um I was just guessing what
could have happened there I'm not
planning to contact I thought I heard
you say that you were going to contact
OS so I was just getting clarification
thank you I I have spoken to OS many
times that's what I was talking
yeah
sorry I I got a question we have um
within the university system granted
guarantee which is a grant which takes
care of the tuition okay of students
which are coming from a certain level of
income okay would this program be
available to those which are also
receiving that
Grant as written I don't see why not but
I don't see why an amendment couldn't be
written to uh um to take care of those
cases thank you no words further
represent
Amon um can you speak to what if any
other states have programs similar to
this or to any part of this since
there's clearly three um sort of three
programs in
here um well so as I said I I was
talking to him as he was writing this
bill coming up with a concept for it um
I don't remember him referring
specifically to any other um states with
similar programs um however the the way
it's funded um with with Lottery uh
money um because this is education
related that would be a pretty standard
way of of funding um in other states as
well from my understanding um but no I
don't know of of other states with
similar
programs thank you any further questions
from the committee not seeing thank you
thank you very much Andrew thank you so
much are there any other people in our
audience today desirous of speaking on
this bill not seeing we will close the
hearing on HB
minutes
e
okay we're ready to go ahead on HB
770 um is the prime sponsor the bill
here she is oh okay we we need to have a
card filled out
young man who has worked on this bill
with me he sit me and also
testify I'd rather you present it and
then he can fill a card out too and then
that okay i' like to uh welcome
represent Schultz to our our meeting
today to present 770 this is relative to
establishing a program to earn tuition
credits for the State of New Hampshire
higher education institutions through
community service
welcome thank you Mr chair it's great to
see you again and for those of you who
are new or actually everyone's new to
this
committee um it's an honor to be here
and to see some of you uh again and so
new new people great to see you as well
um this bill was presented uh last
session it is uh the complete idea of a
constituent uh from conquer who's now in
college at the time she was a high
school student she now at Harvard uh
down at Harvard um and it's simple in
this way um the details maybe are not
but uh really was to look at three key
components that we call the um you know
the triple uh play so um um one it's to
increase uh interest in and activity
among high school students at whether
regardless of where or how they attend
high school to uh do service projects or
become interns and volunteers with uh as
you know in high school so to increase
service programs which a lot of high
schools have um you know like a whole
junior year service project but to
increase that sort of thing across the
state um to
engage uh high school students in a way
that this is the second part to earn
tuition credits for our state
institutions of Higher Learning here in
New Hampshire and uh three to increase
access to
Affordable um attendance at said
University by giving college credits for
having done this volunteer work so that
that's the those are the three points
Vol increasing
volunteerism
um engaging students in that and
increasing that in high schools and in
providing a more affordable access to
our higher uh education institutions
through that volunteer work and that is
the Crux of it um I there were many
great suggestions that were um made as
this bill was I believe
retained
um I'm not sure I have those notes so I
need to track those down but um I would
recommend retaining the bill for that
purpose
um and of course I defer to the
committee's
wishes it will be your bill now um and I
think that's the Crux of my presentation
and Ryan Casey uh the brother of Morgan
Casey has also been working on this bill
um and he will be testifying and fill
out a pink card also
so and that's it thank you very much
other questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you Mr chair and committee Mr
Casey do you have a pin
card yeah they're right over there to
your
right you can go ahead and and and start
testifying just please you know submit
one when you're when you're
completed and welcome to education fing
thank
you my name is Ryan Casey I'm a junior
Bishop Brady High School thank you Mr
chairman and the committee for allowing
me to speak it's an honor to be here
today to speak on behalf of House Bill
770 also known as the triple win
policy my sister Morgan and I have
worked with representative Schultz on
this bill over the last year and a half
to make higher education attainable and
affordable to everyone interested in
pursuing it
over 43 million Americans hold federal
student loans totaling over $1.7
trillion with 74% of New Hampshire
college graduates facing student loan
debt this proposal aims to Institute a
unique option for tuition credit to
alleviate future loan debt within our
state it also provides value in serving
the community and getting to know New
Hampshire outside of the
classroom House Bill 770 benefits three
groups
significantly first New Hampshire
students gain a unique opportunity to
avoid heav heavy student loan debt
through community service exposing
students to the challenges faced by
others would promote a heightened
awareness of of the broader Community
second communities benefit from
enthusiastic students engaging in
volunteer work especially in areas
facing staff shortages consistent
support throughout the year would yield
a greater impact than sporadic help
third the state of New Hampshire would
benefit from this policy by encouraging
ambitious young adults to pursue higher
education locally increased volunteer
work would create valuable connections
for future employment and motivate
students to engage with
nonprofits by studying and building
relations in state these students are
more likely to establish permanent
careers in New Hampshire helping to
retain exceptional
talent I believe this proposed
legislation has the potential for
transformative change it encourages
volunteer work strengthens communities
and helps alleviate student loan burdens
New Hampshire could set an example for
other states with this triple win policy
which reflects a compromise between
Democrats and Republicans I urge New
Hampshire Congress to consider this and
pass this Bill thank you thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee represent fellows um yes I'm I
just read it quickly but it's it sounds
to me
like the people who are eligible could
be somebody from out of state attending
a a CO College in New Hampshire no the
the idea is that it's only available to
um New Hampshire High School students to
University oh okay further questions
from the commit represent
papovich thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming and testifying I know
it's not always easy to uh you know be
on camera and in front of a committee um
you ended your um testimony by saying
this is a compromise between the
Democrats and the Republicans could you
help me understand a bit more what did
you mean specifically by
that yes I think that um there's a
democratic side that uh they want
student Lo forgiveness and
there's been proponents of Simply
erasing a lot of student loans and I
think that this um satisfies the
Republican side of the argument
because while it's helping
students or alleviate their student
loans there is also benefit to the
community and through this volunteer
work thank you that's very insightful I
appreciate it further questions from the
committee
yes thank you um Mr chair and thank you
for for testifying and thank you for
taking my question um and then maybe
this is a question for the
representative but um it says that high
school students attending private high
schools or prep schools would not be
eligible and can you speak to that why
they wouldn't be
eligible well says high school students
attending private high schools or
preparatory schools shall not be
wait a minute let's let's let's we may
want to ask that question to the prime
sponsor here in a second but uh are
there any more questions for the Mr
Casey
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh you said
you're a senior in high school I'm a
junior you're a junior in high school um
If This Were offered to you would you be
more attracted to go to New Hampshire
University yeah
at your school you're going to a public
school no I go to Bishop Brady Bishop
Brady okay U follow up question let's
let's let's say conquer high so so are
you at Bishop Brady are you required to
do community service yes I'm required to
do 25 so this would actually give give
more compensation for the for the
service that you're actually required to
do then I think that the um some of the
revisions we made to the bill were to
exclude all mandatory service hours for
uh schools I appreciate what you did
thank you thank you further
questions not see you thank you very
much I also could address the question
on you may yes public school students I
think that the main idea behind that was
because public school students are um
definitely from New Hampshire whereas
prep schools take students from all
across the country and sometimes other
countries and then private schools as
well can
um have students from the nearby States
attending thank you very
much not see any other questions thank
you and uh I'll right back represent
asked are you satisfied with that
response okay fine so no need to come
back thank you uh I don't have any other
pck cards I have one though from the
Department for technical report on this
bill uh Steve Appleby Steve would you
forward thank you Mr chair members of
the committee Steve applebe Department
of Education um we had submitted a
fiscal note but I we must have missed
the deadline because it didn't make it I
noticed in the attachment it looks like
um I would be happy to read the fiscal
note language if that would be of help
to the committee
um I do have a
revised uh fiscal note 23 February 3 I
have an initial fiscal note of
128 uh I'm that doesn't look like the
costs have changed a heck of a lot so
would you please speak to those y so um
thank you the the fiscal note that I had
submitted that um stated that the
department would need we estimate uh at
least three full-time staff members to
implement the proposed system and to
track the hours and students uh the
staff for cost uh and there was a cost
worksheet attached would be between 100
500,000 a year um the total number of
Staff needed Beyond this is
indeterminant as it is unknown how many
students up to
1253 seniors this year uh could take
advantage of this and would be eligible
and we further don't know how many
post-secondary students um could be
eligible
additionally we would need to set up a
tracking system some type of software
product that would then need to be
maintained to track this uh and this
stems from the wording um beginning
Roman numeral 6 the commissioner of the
Department of Education shall adopt
rules um relative to approved volunteer
sites participating schools and inations
of higher education student eligibility
criteria and distribution of tuition
credits um Department shall also develop
forms in collaboration with the
participating organizations and
educational institutions to Document
program participant participation and
volunteer service so that would lead us
to believe that we would uh uh need need
staff to implement this program so um
because we we imagine that we would have
to go out and visit sites to make sure
that they complied with some set of
rules and then um track track students
and work with institutions on the
credits so so I just wanted to make sure
that the committee was aware of that are
there questions yes represent spillsbury
thank you uh do you interpret this the
way that I do uh that it would be the
department of education's responsibility
for approving uh the various volunteer
sites or organizations and would have to
keep one Statewide Master list for every
Community or District yes uh thank you
for the question yes that that is how we
interpreted this that that's sounds like
a very large job just to even gather the
information let alone to uh tabulate it
follow up yes and uh you mentioned the
12,500 or so uh seniors but as I read
the bill any high school student would
be able to get started on this as as
early as ninth grade and accumulate
credits for the ultimate graduation and
and college Years so wouldn't that
number be perhaps four times as
many yes thank you it could be I had to
start somewhere so I I pick seniors okay
thank you represent fellows um yes my
question is how this might coordinate
with other um programs that we already
have as in incentives to stay in for
high school students to to go to um
higher education in New Hampshire so can
you tell us what the current programs
are is there still some kind of um
tuition reduction for student that that
graduate in the top tier of their class
or any programs like that uh thank you
for the question representative so um
there may be some programs at the local
college level are that are in in place
for students but at the Statewide level
programs yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for being here and
helping us
is the
1253 number that's the number of high
school
seniors uh well it says 24 so last year
that's the total
number so then this calculation is based
on thinking that all of those High
School seniors are going to stay in New
Hampshire and go to one of our uh state
funded
institutions again thank
you not probable but we also don't have
visibility into how many stay how many
go so um that
12503 number is a worst case scenario um
but likewise as uh the representative
said that's only one grade of the four
and then there's also an eligibility
component with the existing
postsecondary students in our public
colleges
so uh we really it's it's it could be
very little cost or it could be tens of
thousands of students we really don't
have a a good
idea yes
may do we have data on how many New
Hampshire graduating seniors do stay in
New Hampshire for higher ed not and
whether they stay and go to community
collegey University or private
institutions yes we do have some data on
that um numbers off the top of my head I
can get them to the chair to share with
the committee thank
you further questions
not see thank you very much thank you
are there any other pink cards on this
bill
770 not seeing any I will close is that
a pin card coming for this no oh another
one okay oh okay thank you so with that
yeah
e
on the committee the there are two
policy areas they don't even have to
have Financial notes that this committee
will get quer technical education
and higher
education and this is one of those in
the higher education side dealing with
the higher education commission which is
a commission which approves all new
institutions and institutions for higher
education in the state we authorize as a
legislature their recommendation comes
to us
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee step applebe dep director
Department of Education um just a quick
background on the higher education
commission um this years ago was was
called the postsecondary education
commission and then in 2011 morphed into
the higher education commission uh the
commission's responsibilities include
rul making around um uh private colleges
licensed postsecondary vocational career
schools so if you think um a HVAC school
or a computer training school or dog we
have dog grooming training schools that
teach folks how to um uh make a vocation
of something um as the chair pointed out
uh the commission also approves new
colleges which then come to this body to
be um given degree granting Authority
within the state of New Hampshire uh and
lastly uh the committee oversees the
administration of a very small
scholarship for Orphans uh veterans um
that scholarship is up to $2,500 a year
we get 10,000 a year um in our budget to
award so up to
it could be more than four students but
we've never had more than two um due to
other programs available to those
individuals so that's in nutshell what
the committee does uh the commission
does the commission is made up of
college presidents um licensed Career
School representatives and lay members
as well as um within the college
President piece there's uh public
College positions that are in statute
and then there are a number of private
college seats and how that works is the
New Hampshire College University Council
makes a recommendation to the governor's
office the governor's office then um
brings that recommendation to the
executive Council for appointment to the
commission the purpose of this bill and
this is not um my language this was
language that was given to me as I was
just discussing um is to fix a small
issue that has arisen the last few years
and that is if an appointed
non-statutory position so right now for
example the two chancellors of our
public College systems are specifically
named to this
commission this does not affect them
this affects those other seats where the
governor's office makes the nomination
um so for example a private college
president or a lay
person if that member doesn't formally
resign the way the current uh statute is
written the governor's office
interpretate has historically
interpretated this as they are on the
commission until they resign
so striking that language which became
the Genesis of this bill would fix that
problem so if if an individual who is on
the
commission
um doesn't formally resign they move out
of state they retire they become
medically incapacitated and by the way
these are all current situations that we
have the governor's office feels they
cannot reappoint someone to fill that
position because they don't have a
formal resignation so
that said I recognize there are some
questions that have Arisen so we may
want to do some more work on the wording
and consult um consult councel so that
we get the wording exactly right and we
don't have any unintended consequences
so so if you could hang loose there then
I'm going to ask representative F he he
brought some concerns to me right now
and I know he spoke with you let's talk
about that a little bit right
uh thank you Mr
chair I'd be happy to present my
concerns but I'll tell you that I came
to a conclusion as to a better solution
than what we have here but I will
express my concerns and then I think you
ought just put it all on the table here
because I kind of it's hard to
understand what we're trying to do here
fair enough so a as I read this original
statute before we've crossed out the
part we crossed out is that a member
who's appointed uh serves the 5 years
term is ended and now the governor and
Council are obliged or are supposed to
appoint a replacement they haven't
gotten around to it so the member can
stay on so basically Beyond The
Five-Year period as I understand what uh
Mr applebe just explained to us the
problem they're trying to solve is a
member either is no longer active in the
middle of that five-year period or for
instance moves out of state in the
middle of that fiveyear period and in
either case doesn't formally resign so
the governor cannot reappoint somebody
so so I read it as what the goal is is
to solve a problem that's happening
midterm I.E between zero and 5 years as
opposed to this which seems to be
killing the possibility for a person to
stay on Beyond 5 years until their
position is filled by the governor so
okay that's where I'm coming from in
terms of my concern about this I have a
question though for Mr Appleby if I may
yes go ahead so would it be possible to
Simply uh eliminate the commission and
Grant the what the few authorities that
are left to the
commissioner of Education y thank you
for the question um it would be I mean
i i before I let that go with another
one representa just posed something that
I you know if we look at everything that
this commission does when we're talking
about the presidents that are on this
the chancellors which are on this we're
dealing with nii we're dealing with with
the accreditation process and we're
looking at the the fiscal backing of
various people that are applying to
become a college or university or or an
adult ed type training program in the
state other words a person pays their
tuition to go to school and then they go
bankrupt how do they get their tuition
money back so what's the bonding and all
that we're going to place all this on
one commissioner or are we going to put
it on um
these
Commissioners I guess if we're going to
go that way then we got to really do
some work here um the other thing is
there's 12
appointed
members those appointed
members also have responsibilities where
it says I'm looking at where six
representes of the private four-year
colleges in New Hampshire appointed by
the governor of Council on
recommendation by New Hampshire college
and university council with no more than
one representative from any one
college what happens if the commissioner
decides to haul off and go to West
Virginia and no longer work for White
Mountain Community College or for one of
those
system can they be a commissioner if
they're no longer from one uh one
college and I'm assuming any one college
I'm assuming that's a college in our
state not something in West Virginia
so I I guess can you explain that a
little bit to us then I'm going to go
with the questions
and yeah yeah so thank you I I think
just to clarify if I understand the
question what's are you asking what's
the difference if a Chancellor were to
leave versus a private college President
and this language right is that I'm not
worried about the chancellor leaving I'm
not worried about the college President
leaving because they will be replaced
either by interim or what have you by
the
trustees I'm concerned about the a
person appointed by the governor and
councel that in conjunction with the
rest of that sentence uh with no more
than one represent from any one college
so you don't don't want two people
representing you know the same
college so they have to be a
representative of a college is do we
have something wrong in our language
chair should be a college in New
Hampshire no so no um elsewhere we
specify resident of the state as I read
it
but if one of those six were to leave
were to leave their position at their
college become medically incapacitated
no longer be a resident of the state
whatever the reason and they don't
submit a
formal resignation to the governor's
office the governor's office as of last
fall did not feel comfortable appointing
a new person even if their term had
expired because the the language up
above the language up above
States
um the terms of appointed members except
as otherwise indicated above so those
would be the the public college
appointees and the the commissioner of
education and so forth um the terms of
appointed members except as otherwise
indicated above shall be for five years
qualified the next sentence okay
vacancies yeah of course there wouldn't
be a vacancy because they're they
haven't vacated yeah so I think that
their hangup
is their hangup is and until the
successor is appointed and verified so
it's that
and I again I'm not an attorney May Mr
yeah because he okay so it sounds like I
can see how this would work it sounds
like well we'll let him hang out there
in Utah or wherever until this five
years and then his terms expired so that
it's that's how they're fixing the
problem but that still potentially
leaves four years 11 months 30 days of
an empty seat so this still doesn't seem
quite right and just to follow my
earlier question how many or my earlier
point when you talk about the
authorities of this commission what
authorities are
what what what is the totality of the
authorities that the commission
currently has yes so
um
approving uh colleges or universities so
that then they can come before the
legislature to gain degree granting
Authority um so that's that's one scope
of responsibility also um
overseeing postsecondary licensed
vocational career schools and that
process we have a set of administrative
rules governing that process um admin
during the war in
scholarship those are the three primary
areas of responsibility for the higher
education commission and of course Ru
making around to govern all of
that so thank you could you just and
then represent spb could you please
explain to what we have done we've
approved the American college in Lebanon
we've uh approved colleges in Italy
we've approved Cornell as a recognized
College in the state even though they're
not planted here they're authorized to
function here right um is that not a
very real important issue to ensure
these places were approving meet all the
standards expective of a higher
education
institution so um we have there have
been two new colleges in the last seven
years started within our state both
online colleges um my office um led the
review teams of both of those colleges
on behalf of the commission and then
presented the findings to the commission
uh and um the results of that that
review of those two institutions and did
look at things like Financial Security
and bonding and programmatic efficacy um
their mission you know what they they
see themselves doing so the office did
do that work on behalf of the commission
then presented to the commission uh we
do have colleges non non-public or
private colleges um both in New
Hampshire as well as we have two
currently overseas that are approved
helenic American and um university of
MBA American University of MBA and we do
not anticipate getting any more foreign
institutions at this time because Nei
has changed how they accredit it used to
be for a foreign non- us institution to
gain Nei accreditation Nei is the
regional accreditor for many of most of
our colleges in our state uh it used to
be to gain
accreditation through Nei you had to had
State approval first and Nei has
repealed that rule so now now uh the
third college that we were working with
several years ago that was overseas has
since um pulled out of getting our
approval and is just working directly
with Nei so um we don't anticipate any
more foreign institutions like what we
used to see years ago um but with regard
to within the state if the chair wanted
to start a new college tomorrow um the
process is uh we have a bunch of forms
and the chair would submit those forms
on behalf of his Institution
we would then set up a time to conduct a
review and then we would present those
findings to the commission um and if
approved then that institution could
seek a legislative sponsor to gain
degree granting Authority from the
state represent spillsbury
thank you Mr chair so when I read the
bill as drafted I assumed that it was
addressing a holdover problem when I
listen to you I hear that it's uh really
meant to address a a inactive members
problem perhaps it should be Rewritten
to address
both and uh so my question is
um how important is the problem should
we work on revising this or should we
abandon
it thank you for the question well um we
currently have two
seats that are that are an
issue where individuals have left the
state no longer represent institutions
one is I Ally incapacitated so we still
have we have two current issues that are
still on the commission that can't exit
off oh yes okay so you're saying you'd
like a bill now as to making a bill that
will actually do what you
want um I I'm certainly been involved in
any number of organizations that have a
rule such as uh if a member is uh
inactive for three or more meetings and
you know you can you can uh uh play with
that variable um then in effect the seat
becomes vacant is deemed vacant that
still begs the question that this last
sentence vacancies shall be filled for
an unexpired term that doesn't really
say how and when and by whom um so
wouldn't it make sense to flesh each of
those thoughts
out yes thank
you and would he be willing to do
it would you care to work
with thank you I welcome the opportunity
thank you thank you thank thank you very
much represent
bricky so you we have two seats do like
does the commission reach out to those
Commissioners and say hey what's
up yes and they don't yes well that's
thanks represent Burton uh just a quick
question uh
half a century ago Governor sonono uh
had me represent him because they were
looking at a new program at a trade
school is that do they do just new
institutions or do they do programs also
that not commission that would be a a a
question for so um the commission does
not have jurisdiction over our public
College systems it's it's strictly uh
the private colleges and um how it works
is if if the ABC private college has um
baloria level approval from their
Regional
accreditor they may add new
programs at any time if those new
programs are outside of their mission
let's say they are a liberal arts
college and they are starting their
first four-year nursing program they
would seek what we call an
administrative review from the
commission and we would review that
program and present the findings to the
commission for approval further further
question yes um would you believe that
when we visited the school that was
going to add a master's degree
in uh child education we found that that
they were going to do it by starting a
daycare center and they were declined
and and my would you believe it's
important that this
commission be be staffed fully and
skillfully with people know what they're
doing that's probably a rhetorical
question
yes further
questions yes representative pison
represent Damon so I'm I'm just trying
to clarify where we are I'm not um so
there are two
vacancies that have been well they're
not vacant there are two seats that
nobody has put their um sat in in for
months are those positions that were
appointed by the governor did you say
that so the the non-statutory positions
that those buckets of four and six are
are nominated by the governor and
appointed by the
council
question my followup the the I'm asking
which ones are the uh situation where
they're not showing up yes we have um
one um former College president and one
um licensed Career School representative
and those just those are those are not
appointed by the governor those they
both are they both yes private college
presidents are appointed by the
executive counsil and nominated by the
governor and so what is the reason that
they're not they're just saying because
they're
not I I'm not buying
that so so just my what I'm trying to
figure out is that there are the
governor appoints many many people to
many many commissions so I don't
understand if how this situation relates
to a fix here if the go if the question
is whether or not the governor can fill
a um assume that a person has resigned
because they haven't shown up then that
would not be dealt with here that would
be dealt somewhere with in the statutes
related to what the governor and councel
sense okay I thought he was gonna there
was a question here and I on her yeah I
I was he was you asked a question and I
was going to have him respond to your
question I I think I can answer your
question yeah if that's okay yeah okay
so and I I'll grant you that the way
this statute is written as I was trying
to explain is not as thorough as it
could be but as I read the statute
currently a position never opens up if
the member does not resign because after
five years they can hang they can hang
in
there because the position is still is
still nobody's been reappointed but but
if we change the rule way the law the
way they are asking us to
then after 5 years they are
automatically resigned as I read it and
at that point the position opens up and
the governor could could to replace them
but these two positions these two people
he's talking about currently apparently
their five years is up I can't I don't
know that or not but this is with okay
well when the five years is up so
whenever that happens sometime down the
road the governor would be able to
reappoint them but currently couldn't as
I was suggesting more along the lines of
what you're talking about in fact we
should and also represent spillsbury we
probably should be a little tighter than
that even and if you don't show up for
some number of meetings or whatever in
addition to this whole thing um just so
yeah I don't want to get too much in
this executive session type discussion I
know but uh we need to filter through
this a little bit of here um one more
and then I'll go to D just I'm just
wondering if represent um Earth sees
agrees that it's a issue that would
apply to more than just this one
commission I I think what we ought to do
is before answering that question by
anybody right here we're getting into
that next
portion and and and if you want to go
that way with your question that's
fine because he could help you out with
the a response here oh okay represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I have two
things if I may
so the first I guess I'm looking for a
confirmation that our discussion is
indicating there's two problems to
solve so one is the you're at the end of
your five-year term and the language
does not clearly say that you're done
and someone can either you can be
reappointed or someone else can be
appointed so that seems like a fairly
straight forward uh address and then the
other is this issue of the mid midterm
lack of
participation so is that correct that we
really need two
solutions I thank you potentially yes so
okay and then if I may one more yes
thank you so in the statute um let me
get the right part here
sorry where it
references um the members appointed by
the governor and councel etc
etc um
so it says six representatives of the
private four-year colleges in New
Hampshire appointed by the governor and
Council on recommendation and the
limitation of no more than one rep from
any one college I don't read that to say
that those Representatives have to be in
New Hampshire they have to
represent private fouryear colleges in
New Hampshire but they don't have to be
here seemed like there was discussion
that suggested they did have to be New
Hampshire
residents I think by practice that's
been the case so we could certainly if
we're fixing language elsewhere we could
certainly add that in as
well that was my initial comment yeah
one college
Hampshire so do we
want so if I were serving
on in that role and I relocated out of
state I'm not sure that necessarily
diminishes the person's capacity to
serve so I don't know what you want
there but I guess that needs some
clarification I think the wording would
speak to it being a New Hampshire
approved
institution but not necessarily a
resident so if you are the president of
ABC College ABC college is an online
college but it is Incorporated in New
Hampshire degree granting Authority from
the
legislature than that
person yeah are there further questions
of Mr
be not seeing thank thank you very much
thank
you are there any other pink cards on
hearing that the bill needs work
definitely definitely yeah I know what
quickly
e
that if that can go that way wait minute
this let's see yeah and this can go that
way there there's ample there
around okay I'm going to open the
hearing on HB
718 an act requiring the State Board of
Education to report the unfunded
Financial impact to school districts for
rules adopted by the board which exceed
state or federal minimum standards and
we will hear from sponsor representative
lad thank you very much represent
spillsbury and members of the education
funding committee for the record my name
is Rick lad I come from hail New
Hampshire uh representing Grafton
5 uh today I'm introducing this bill uh
which requires the State Board of
Education to report the unfunded
Financial impact to school districts for
rules adopted by the board which exceed
standards for years we've been trying to
cut back in some of the rules that the
legislature always attaches to some Bill
and sometimes the when we put F uh the
the reference to rule making in in the
bill it's very Broad and very it doesn't
speak to a specific area where the
legislature is supposed to make rule
making I think that my Approach is that
we have to talk about this term of
deregulation stopping all the rules to
allow people to function and know what's
coming at them that may exceed law and
within law I've handed out a sheet to
you which looks at 186 C co 16- uh C and
that's rules exceeding state or federal
minimum requirements so we have given
authority to the Department of Education
to extend rules that
exceed our laws or fate or state federal
laws and on the backside of the first
sheet there's an area on 186c which I
took out a statute which gives the rule
making Authority
when you're sticking in the terminology
RSC
541a that's meaning you're going to do
make rules in accordance with what we
have in statute it's going to have to be
looked at by gel car and there those
rules are going to have to be approved
by the State Board of
Education item number eight underneath
rulemaking authorities other matters
relating to complying with provisions of
this chapter it's very broad it's very
broad that means that they're pretty
much given a blank check
in terms of what they can make rules
for we do have within statute on the
first side there on the first sheet
where we say for each rule or proposed
rule contained in the report there's a
report which is due annually to the to
to
us and it's spelled out by December one
of each year the commissioner Department
of Education shall issue a report for
all special education rules proposed or
adopted which exceed the minimum
standards etc etc
um for each rule or proposed rule
contained in the report the State Board
shall include one the rule
number two the nature of the rule three
any state minimum requirement
exceeded any federal minimum requirement
exceeded and jumping over number five
there the reasons for exceeding those
minimum requirements those are in law
right now the report has to contain that
and if you look at the the last sheet I
have for you and I'm going to go back
and talk about number five here in a
second but there is a form which is the
devel the state board has
developed uh New Hampshire standards in
excess chart and the chart below it's
it's one of 17
Pages which stipulates the standards the
rules
ed102 01f and it goes right down all
those rules I only gave page one of 17
to you I wanted you to know that there
is a format which they have to report to
us annually on those rules which exceed
and the nature of the standard and that
tells you just broadly well this is for
adult students okay State minimum
requirement exceeded yes it that
particular ed1
102.0 does exceed there is no comparable
language in RSA
186c there's rationale for why they do
have to exceed I understand that I'm not
objecting to
that federal minimum requirement
exceeded in this particular case on Ed
yes there is no comparable Federal
language for uh emancipated
minor going on language in the standard
so it list the standard and reason for
exceeding that standard this is
information which is submitted publicly
and
available what I've heard from a number
of folks in the field over my years of
being here that when we adopt these
rules what is the corresponding cost to
implement this Rule and by doing so are
we going Beyond what's being funded to
us through adequacy or through
catastrophic Aid or whatever it may be
within the education statutes the
annotated
statutes and it it does uh because we
have this broad other rules you know as
as stated right there on the on the rul
making side other matters related to
complying with provisions of this
chapter it's pretty wide open game and
so I'm introducing this bill because I'd
like to see in the in the legislation
the unfunded Financial impact on local
school DS for Rural on districts for
rules exceeding state or federal minimum
requirements I'm not saying you
shouldn't do it I'm saying what are the
costs to doing
this and you know and speaking just a
second ago with our our chair of the of
the State Board I understand where Mr
kin's coming from that's going to be an
expense or a cost to putting this all
together I get it I understand that but
somewhere along the way we have to
realize that the more rues we make the
more cumbersome it is to do our business
especially when we're seeing the
demographic in the state declining the
funding situations which we're
encountering we need to be cautious on
what we're doing and we need to know
what's going on with some of these rules
and for me I got to know the fiscal
impacts you know the rule number I know
the rule number I know you know all the
other stuff that's listed there and I
can read the rational up top of why they
have to exceed
so that's it in a nutshell of what we're
trying to do this bill is trying to do
not we I am trying to do and I'm I'm
open to any
questions thank you very much uh yes
representative bricky thank you thank
you um and thank you representative lad
for answering my question so do you
envision like one
more column on this chart that has money
and if there's yes if there is an
adopted rule or a rule that's in place
and it's causing that local school board
this type of
cost and it may be a justifiable cost oh
yeah but I I think that we need to know
that in order to make the decisions
which we're making to be a little bit
more cautious sometimes when we're
making
rules or approving them through Jael
card I know that as chair of this body
and chair of the education committee
last year we were asked to review every
new rule that's being proposed or being
renewed every 10 years the committee has
that task and to communicate then with
the chair of Jael
car somebody that represent McGuire
knows very very
well uh to inform them of the impacts
that that may
have you're welcome representative pep
Miller thank you Mr chairman and thank
you chairman lad for
presenting this bill I completely agree
with the spirit of it my one concern is
about the use of the word unfunded
instead of say additional Financial
impact because I'm trying to understand
whether that put a burden on the State
Board of Education to judge what is
unfunded and what is not while if we
simply said additional Financial impact
that would remove the the need for them
to make determination which is really a
legislative determination and would
still provide us with the information
that we need in terms of the financial
impact of the rules that exceed the
minimum standards I I what you're saying
to me is logical and maybe we have to
look at that you just use the term the
financial impact you took the unfunded
out of it uh so you know the financial
impact is what we want to know how is
this impacting that District that really
doesn't have the resources to comply y
thank
you representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so would
you believe that uh representative Carol
McGuire is no longer the chair or vice
chair of Jael car and uh she's she's
sort of winding down and handed the
house leadership position to
representative Lon all right so um let
me ask
this is this something that um the board
when they make such a rule can answer
right I mean is this a number that they
can always come up with are they like
have the capability of the LBA or
something that they can write a fiscal
note sort of like
this that might be a a question
you if Drew is going to be coming up
here I I would May pose that to him you
know we a lot of this you're estimating
the cost too you don't you don't they're
indeterminable in many ways but uh it
helpful if we we knew that and if
districts know that as well and yeah I
do apologize I re I know repr McGuire is
not there anymore I was on it with her
and she lasted a long time and I got off
could representative Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
which you may defer to Mr Klein based on
your response to representative Maguire
but
I'm puzzling a bit
over what I would perceive as a
difference in financial impact of say
any particular rule isn't going to have
the same Financial impact to every
school district so is this proposed Bill
looking for a summary number of the
financial impact of a rule to all the
districts or something different from
that I have haven't given it that type
of thought you know I was looking on
average or but to say the financial
impact of a b c d going on down through
all those districts I think that'd be a
very difficult job Senor talking about
Manchester with 13 plus thousand kids
and then or so and then you're talking
about cuden and those that area yours
you know 100 kids I roughly two okay so
the impacts are going to be different
but proportionally there's still an
impact
because your revenues are not the same
of what the other larger district
has yes F so thank you for that that's
why I asked the question that it would
be considerably different impact in
different districts and I'm not
clear whether the cost of a particular
rule would be the same per student so
I'm not I'm not disagreeing about the
need to look at the fiscal impact of the
rules that we make I'm just trying to
understand
and how this bill would be this proposed
bill would be implemented uh in a
practical and not
overly
um costly way like the cost of of
collecting the
data I'm not sure that's a question
sorry I'm asking for your
comment I don't have a specific answer
to that question uh it's there there's
going to be some rules that don't even
apply to certain
districts um other districts are going
to get hammered um and in and and some
some and I agree many of our rules we
have to go a little bit further because
it's not really defined well within the
state or federal law and it leaves a
hole and that's what it basically says
in the top part on the on the small
print that's necessary um if we're going
to travel that we're and we're the one
passing it anyways with the it's coming
from the legislature so we do discuss
that uh I am primarily concerned about
the cost to these districts that certain
rules have that costs are not met
through the revenue picture which
state okay representative
Ames
yeah interesting proposal uh
I'm wondering if the uh history we have
experience we have with fiscal notes
might
inform uh how best to approach this new
requirement
um you know we we see in fiscal notes
often the word
indeterminable and um that sort of is an
escape clause for the agencies that just
can't really figure it out because there
are too many uncertainties out there and
there's no softening of this requirement
it's thought there might be a financial
impact while by goly you got to figure
it out um you know so I'm I'm suggesting
and asking if you think we might uh
pause and look at other experiences that
would help us help everybody understand
what's now being required of this agency
rep Ames I agree with you
that there is no fiscal note on this
right here in this
bill um it has a March 20 deadline it's
not an early bill it can be retained
it's one of those types of bills the
concept why or principle wise there
there's some rationale for it but
there's unended cost here maybe that you
know the depart or a costs which the
department is going to have to incur to
do this and can we acquire how it
impacts as representative Damon says one
District versus another District um it
it does need work in that but I think
it's something which we need to look at
and and and address uh is one of those
and and I I know that it's been put out
to legislators that we really encourage
you everybody to slow down on the ru
making for all these and if you have to
have Ru making do it specifically to one
particular element within the
legislation don't get broad General
rulemaking uh too many unended
consequences as a result of that um we
ask for those other five
components why we're exceeding the state
why we're exceeding the minimum what is
the standard and I think there's also
the we need to have a little bit better
understanding what are the costs
associated
costs and representative ases and can I
can I ask you together with uh
representative lad I think
representative lad was interpreting your
question is whether there should be a
fiscal note to this bill but I wasn't
your question whether the model of a
fiscal note would lend itself well to
this and be used in the rul making
process so yes that's something that I I
like that track yes I thought it was an
excellent question I wanted to make sure
we hit it um it's an interesting concept
whether that might be a little bit more
of a flexible approach than uh a hard
number in a chart representative fellows
um thank you I'm I'm quite quite sure
that when rules are proposed there's a
question on the rules form that
addresses is this going to have a
financial impact and on whom and that's
kind of like a you might think of it as
being kind of like a fiscal note but I
think the way the language is in here
it's not that necessarily the department
would have to say you know it's going to
cost you know
$2.2 million or whatever across the
state it can be more like a fiscal more
like a statement that says you know if
you're changing the age of of when um
the special ed students can remain from
20 to through 21 than just saying
something like that means that you know
about X number of students for every
student that stays an extra year is
going to have a cost for the district
even if you don't put an exact number on
it that's an important piece of
information I agree with that we we went
through that business up to age 20 22
other words through 21 and there were
there are real implications in terms of
finances on that especially when we
start start talking about the special
education Aid um we we did discuss that
when we passed up to age
21 um but you're on the right track
there and I I think that
this I I don't think this is ready yet
but the concept I'm trying to propose is
that we need to be doing something so uh
when uh Jael cars and trying to figure
out what this is all about they have
some better fiscal understanding some of
these bills that come through are very
innocuous and I can remember one I put
through that was Capital Improvements
for Statewide fairs the ru making
process took over two years for
$250,000 and and it
so that whole process needs a little bit
of
thought I have a question um and and I I
agree I think this can be worked um but
when we use adjectives like unfunded to
modify Financial impact or exceeding uh
minimum standards it it makes me wonder
whether the rule making Authority in the
first instance was tightly enough drawn
right so for example in uh 186 c16 which
you handed out subparagraph 8 that that
uh loose last phrase other matters
related to related to is a very loose
phrase yeah you know why wouldn't that
be better rephrased as other matters
required to comply and then you get
right back to your language in this bill
which is requirements why are we
exceeding requirements in the first
place yes and that yeah that the last
part of the first part there the the
rule make other matters that sounds like
lawyer talk to me it's you know we use
terms like reasonable well you try to
Define reasonable sometimes you know uh
I see it coming through it all the time
and so you know given that clock here I
think what we ought to do is conclude my
testimony here move
question oh represent Damon sorry not
turning thank you
kindly is this is this for this would
you please comment on the
possible perhaps unintended consequence
of doing this
work on the likelihood of having
less statutes that exceed or rules that
standards you're going to have some
statutes that require you to have new
labor within your building but under the
guys of special Eden we can pass that
type of legislation but we don't have to
pass the dollars to support
it to me that's going to be the impact
it's going to be the impact to the
district trying to figure out where
they're going to take it and they're
going to be taking it from Peter to pay
paal so I don't know if that answers
where you're coming from on that
uh the this is an issue which as is
age-old issue that needs I think
consideration and where we have a
special committee here to do that right
now I thought it might be one that we
into yes represent fellas thank you and
um you mentioned that you had been on
you you you've been on Edna and where I
was served also and I'm currently on
Jael car so don't you do you think that
this is also important information for
Jael car because
your proposal is that the uh legislature
here sees it first before this is
supposed to be prepared before Jael car
has to make a decision on new rules is
that correct well I've never been on Eda
Edna I thought but I was on Jael car and
and and uh many of us have been on Jael
car uh that's the last step and and and
and then you you know can do things
conditionally what Happ you uh then it
goes back to the the bureau or the
department or the board that's coming
from and they ultimately make the final
decision
so okay well that was quite a round of
questions thank you very much thank you
speak so Drew Klein chairman of the
State Board of Education right um thank
you Mr chairman for the record Drew
Klein chairman of the State Board of
Education I didn't fill out a pink slip
I just come to observe but I think it
would be useful uh to sort of get some
perspective here um and maybe answer
questions so I agree with representative
lad entirely on the premise um I can
tell you at the State Board of Education
we work very hard not to exceed any of
our statutory Authority uh I have
instructed all of our attorneys whenever
we have every single rule that comes
before us to make sure that it aligns
with the statutory Authority whether
that's Federal statutes um State
statutes or uh Federal Regulations you
look through the 1100s which are special
education rules and you will see
constant references to cfrs the Federal
Regulations um you know every rule we
write we make a point of spelling out
where we get the authority to do it and
what the parameters of that Authority is
so we try to stay within that
um what we don't do is the financial
impact analysis we're just not equipped
to do that but um it's a fair question
so whenever we take on revising our
rules um this particular board is always
looking at them and
questioning why do we have this mandate
on school districts what do it
accomplished can we accomplish it in a
less mandatory way um and are there are
there costs to this mandate now we
understand that we can't impose unfunded
costs
but the nature of rulemaking is to
require that districts do certain things
so we're always looking for ways where
we can reduce that burden on districts
but we don't have the capability to do
we don't have a statistician on staff we
don't have an economist we don't have a
an an analyst to do that Financial
impact um assessment so my question uh
on this would be if you want to go
forward I have no objection to us
looking at how our rules impact
districts financially it's a totally
fair thing for us to look at I just
don't know how we're going to execute
this Faithfully with the intent of the
statute very good
questions is there as opposed to a
financial analysis that expects a
quantifiable finite figure
um is there is there a process for
regulatory impact already is that what
this chart we seeing
is not regulatory just speaking more
broadly in terms of impact I mean not
not in the sense of um a sheet that
comes up with an analysis um our our
sort of method of doing this is in the
ru making process from start to finish
we have the Professional Standards Board
we have folks who um get stakeholders
together talk about about what the rules
should be um so we're on a 10-year
conveyor belt all the rules have to be
renewed every 10 years and so when they
come up or when we propose a new rule it
goes through a pretty long process
before it even gets to um us for the
initial proposal by trying to get
stakeholder input um and so in the
process then we have public hearings and
we we hear from districts so that's
really the process where we try to get
that feedback on okay
what's the impact will you guys be able
to execute this is it going to be
burdensome that kind of
thing so it's not it's not really a
mathematical
formula further questions good thank you
I think oh yes Damon thank you thank you
for taking my question it's actually the
same question that I asked
representative lad I would appreciate
your comments on the
possibility of unintended consequences
from doing this meaning that
we did not maintain the same standards
that we now
have that is the standards that are
currently exceeding
minimum which I think we all agree there
are
many does doing this fiscal accounting
if it were to
happen increase the likelihood that we
then have
fewer F RS exceeding the minimum yeah I
I would put it this
way when we we re when we again um take
up rules to revise them um again I've
directed the attorneys to make sure that
the rules that we're proposing do align
with statutory Authority I try not to
ever exceed the minimums if we don't
have to if there's not so for example
I'll show you in this that you've been
given um the examples for exceeding the
minimums typically where where we have
something that you could argue would
exceed the minimum it's because of a
gray area it's because the federal rule
or law or the statute just simply didn't
answer an important question and so
we've got to make a decision over
answering that question so that you
could say that exceeds the the minimum
but um we've had cases where you know
over years where if we don't write a
rule there then we have districts who
have unanswered questions so they're
coming to the department saying what
does this mean what am I allowed to do
and if we don't have a rule that gives
them guidance um they don't have that
guidance
so so we're always striving to keep them
as minimal as possible but there are
areas where you kind of have to go fill
in the blank so to speak um if we had a
financial impact statement I'm not sure
that that would reduce those fill-in the
blank moments um but it might tip the
balance for example so if you had
something that had if we
did some rule that had a really big
Financial impact we might go W I mean I
think our obvious response would be
let's rethink this and not impose this
cost on District so you would probably
end up on the margins with fewer rules
um because you would have that Financial
trigger to give us the red flag that oh
we didn't realize this was going to
impose such a cost but um when you're
thinking about special education costs
if you just go through the 1100s you'll
see how much they align to State
statutes and federal regulations the CFR
is the constant reference in the special
education rules um I would argue that
without having done a a comprehensive
study of it um the costs that get passed
districts implement the rules not a
specific mandate that we put on them
that says you have to do X Y and Z so
um would would this bill actually see a
big reduction in special education costs
probably
not
yeah okay any further questions very
good thank
you uh I have one pink card from Bonnie
dham
thank you bon hi I'm Bonnie Dunham and I
live in marac New Hampshire and I am
here in opposition to this bill um
strong opposition to this bill I left my
son at home this morning after spending
3 days in the hospital with him and
getting 10 hours sleep in 3 days I came
here because this is real important to
the lives of children with disabilities
that that we re that we consider this
bill very very carefully um first I'm
kind of offended because the in the
description it says talks about unfunded
Financial impact for rules for Education
rules why is this amending a special
education law then is it really just
targeting special education costs or
costs for all education roles um it
seems like special education is often
scapegoated as as costing so much um and
it does cost something I'm not going to
deny that um when I was thinking about
this I was thinking about when um Ida
was first passed does people refer to
that as an unfunded mandate in many ways
and does it cost something yes but
before we had that special education law
children with disabilities um were not
allowed to go to school so they either
stayed home and didn't go to school or
they were institutionalized and and
didn't go to school and in the best case
they spent their adult lives doomed to
pretend work to work in a sheltered
workshop um so those lost lives in the
cost of care for those individuals cost
something um and so you have to really
balance the the the the gains against
the costs the the benefits uh you know
do a cost benefit analysis when looking
at that I I think of gross cost versus
net cost when you think about in New
Hampshire um we begin train um preparing
for for postsecondary transition for
children with disabilities by age 14
federal law says by 16 overwhelmingly
Educators um parents came out and
supported keeping it at age 14 because
we believe that better prepares children
for the whole purpose of special
education to leave school prepared to um
either go to work or enter
post-secondary education and New
Hampshire does have a higher percentage
of students leaving school prepared for
those things than other states and so I
I think you can see that while it may
cost something be hard to calculate
actually how much more it takes cost to
send a few minutes at a meeting talking
about that um than just than leaving
that out of the discussion um but if you
consider the children who disabilities
who are now working who might not be
paying taxes who might not be who are
going on to post-secondary education to
have very very productive Lives who
would not have otherwise that you'd have
to subtract that so figure out let's say
it
costs I'm not really good at math
because I'm too tired um let's say it
cost $1,000 for to to begin discussing
that at 14 then somebody pays $10,000 in
extra taxes then that bill really then
that um rule really cost us minus
$9,000 and so that's a savings to the
taxpayer really and I think that because
anytime our special ed rules have been
revised in recent memory there have
always been collaborative opportunities
for parents and Educators and
administrators to talk together and
we've we've jointly testified on in the
past several times because we we know
that there is a benefit for some things
and after careful discussion decided
amongst ourselves as a group it was
worth it and advocated for that the
general education I can only think I
quickly I could think of one thing in
New Hampshire we don't allow children
with or without disabilities to be
beaten or electric shocked like they do
in other school in other states um does
that cost anything I don't know I guess
you have to spend more time managing
children's Behavior if you're not going
to beat or shock them but the cost
savings is that we get to continue
saying we are civilized human
beings thank
you
okay questions
represent thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mrs D for coming over and seriously
for your for the effort that went into
coming here under the circumstances I
hope all will work out well you know in
the short term I just want to understand
a bit better where you're coming from
because during your testimony you said
that we need to do a cost benefit
analysis and then you provided a bunch
of examples where the cost benefit
analysis justifies the Investments I'm
just trying to understand since this
bill just says we want to understand the
financial impact in order to do that
cost benefit analysis why are you
opposing this bill because it doesn't
require cuts it doesn't attack it it
just says we are trying to better
understand what the impacts are so we
can run that cost benefit analysis can
you help me understand that maybe um I'm
not I'm not sure how our your brain and
mind are working together today or not
um and so let's go with that that to
understand the financial impact you have
to understand both what you're spending
and what you're getting for that money
and and this bill only says what are you
spending it doesn't say what are you
getting for that and so you're only
getting half the
picture to do a full analysis it would
take a lot more time I imagine somebody
mentioned fiscal notes I imagine you
would be seeing a lot of rules that for
fiscal notes at indeterminable like you
do so often for regular bills here thank
you very much it really helped me
understand what you're are coming from
thank
you okay other
questions very good good so let me just
ask briefly if what what you're
basically saying is that there should be
a netting of um positives and negatives
two things but if this this is really
focused on out-of-pocket costs of
compliance that doesn't
preclude uh further analysis of what the
benefits uh um or savings um are from
implementing the rule right it just
simply seeks a disclosure if it's
understood in that manner does does it
still bother you yeah um definitely does
because
taxpayers I I go to town meetings and we
I live in marac and recently one of our
budget um committee members said is
there some way we can put a cap on the
number of children with disabilities who
are allowed to move into our town um and
so children with disabilities are
definitely scapegoated I've been at
meetings where people have turned around
my son has been out of school for years
now but previously would say that that's
the reason our our taxes are so high so
if they are only hearing here's how much
it costs and not how much is being saved
or how much is being gained in the long
run then you are further stigmatizing
children with disabilities and and
continuing to make them carry the the
weight of the blame for all of the extra
money taxpayers are having to spend
which is not true and not
fair okay thank you very much thank you
and I'm sure there are millions of
examples but I wrote this in the car on
the way up here um I was dictating to
myself so I could scroll it on this
sheet of paper when I got here I think
you conveyed your thoughts well um
seeing no further questions I don't have
any other pink cards and if there's
nobody else seeking to
testify uh we will close the hearing on
HB
718 and we have a lunch break and we'll
car
e
what get away all right um thank you
everybody for your patience after lunch
uh we're taking up three bills this
afternoon and we'll begin now with HB
771 and in representative Pell's absence
representative lad who is a co-sponsor
will present the
Bill thank you very much Mr chair and
and members of the education funding
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from havil the havil New
Hampshire and representing Grafton 5 I
am a co-sponsor on the bill uh I haven't
really gotten involved with it but I I
I'd like to introduce the bill at least
uh in looking at the bill uh there are
several uh significant changes uh to
current law it should be noted however
that open enrollment schools are schools
where there willing to take tuition
students from another within district
and out of District um and and of course
the cending school is responsible for
paying the cost um if it's from another
District the whole program started back
in
2009 so this is not necessarily in
statute a new
program um the program um has some
basic um
components
um students in the open enrollment
school that are received from a sending
School within the district or a uh
District school not in their district
schools May predetermine the number of
number of students to be accepted in the
program based upon their you know
seating space based upon the type of
program that might be
offered um these open and Roman schools
shall make available uh to the general
public their curriculum and their
policies there's no application fee
other than for app parent just I want to
go to an open school other than that
that uh I'll get into the cost in a
little bit uh on Local School uh sending
in um there is reference given if you're
in the Local District uh to military
personnel children of
military
uh if you're once in an open enrollment
school for second grade let's say and
you've been accepted and you want to
stay for 30 you do not have to apply
twice you you're in you're
in um students are allowed to shift from
one school to another within a district
only one time during the course of a
year here these are some some basic
understandings
um it's done by tuition and the open en
Roman school May limit uh their
population to uh and they may limit to
specific grade level we may be open
enrollment for sixth grade but not fifth
grade or fourth grade due to various
issues might be local issues so they can
limit uh the grade levels available they
can limit it to Agee levels they can
limit it to areas of academic Focus they
can limit to at at risk pupils
vocational education a career type
education they can limit it to only
those students and going into the math
program the science program the Arts the
history languages all that is currently
in
law um students may be selected for an
open uh rment program based upon
aptitude academic achievement need of
the
student uh selection must focus on the
goals of the school the receiving
school that's in law
also um if too many apply trying to get
into an open there's a lottery as we do
have with the charter schools there's a
lottery if there's more people applying
to get in than there are seats available
it's done by
Lottery uh no student can switch schools
more than once in a school year policy
of open enrollment schools have to be
posted um and the policies in the
schools for example if you're coming
from a district that has a different
policy than the district you're going to
the district of the receiving school is
the PO those policies are the policies
in effect for example if you're talking
about suspension expulsion it's not the
sending it's the receiving they decide
whether you're going to get expelled or
not where you're going the Open
Enrollment school has that Authority you
follow their policies where you're are a
student but you're you're listed as a
student though in the sending school
they have the responsibility for the
tuition can be no less than
80% the cost of that sending School
District or as sending
school um There are rules on this uh
541a rules uh now the changes that I see
here uh which uh represent perel house
in the bille there's one area that I
think that deserves some of our
Focus uh is on page two where it says
under budgets each School shall
establish a line item in their operating
budget on an annual basis reflecting
estimated expenditures for an open
enrollment School
tuition by listing it annually and
estimated I that may be difficult to
do uh I haven't given it much thought it
currently says that portion of school
district's estimated expenditures on an
open enrollment School tuition shall be
shown as a separate line in a School
District budget that's the way it was
now it's each School District shall
establish a line item in their operating
budget on an annual basis reflecting
estimated expenditures
so that's all I have to say about it
because I have not gotten on the weeds
I've been working on a lot of other
bills but this one I have not given much
Focus I do believe that open enrollment
schools serve a purpose and and a good
purpose if you have two districts right
beside each other one District may have
a fine mathematics program or a fine uh
career program in in in that school
where the other one doesn't isn't it
wise to send the kids and so you don't
have to duplicate programs and save
costs cost efficiencies that's what this
program really does and it was done way
back in 2009 so at that time uh where
we've gone with some of the education
Choice programs since a lot farther but
this is one that's been established
through a tuition type program from one
District to another and um and this bill
modifies that legislation we've had to
get into the weeds as far as what it
exactly U modifies I I I can't give you
that information right now I haven't
well all right thank you um we do have a
couple of questions are you yep open to
representative
Ames thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question questions plural maybe so
clarification
first how is this different or is it
different
from the many small towns that don't
have education in town at all grade
levels so they have a k to four or k to
six school and then they're paying
tuition
to other schools are those schools open
enrollment schools is that the same
thing no you're talking about a school
for example is School District K through
six K through 8 they don't have high
school right those those schools which
we tuition two are approved by that
sending school board and agreement is
written between the two uh on this
particular situation the receiving
school May declare themselves as an open
enrollment School
and you as a parent in the sending dist
we' like your child to go to that
program so then the school that you're
in has to pay no less than 50% of the
tuition cost to the open enrollment
school that's how I see it it's like a
charter school the parent is saying I
want my child there and and by declaring
themselves I believe there's one open
enrollment school in the state right now
that does this I don't know which one it
is that's if you look in the fiscal
notes that's what that fiscal note says
that's why I was looking just before
this meeting and uh so uh it's it's
running the similar fashion where the
parent says I'd like to have my child
going there um it's a little bit
different than a tuition program where
there's an agreement between the two
districts by school
boards no fa I know what thank you
that's
helpful so related to that on page one
of the bill lines 9 through 14 where
they
Define
um tuition and it
says the pupil's the proposed language
the pupil's sending District shall pay
the receiving District an amount equal
to not less than 80% of the sending
District's average cost per pupil and
goes on so my question relative to that
is am I correct in believing that this
language is setting up a scenario
where a parent could request their child
to go to an open enrollment School whose
average cost per student is considerably
more than the cost at the sending
District I think you're reading it
correctly school will have to accept
that
yes
interesting thank you okay
representative
I I'm pausing on this line
item um rephrasing of the line
item uh section subsection and uh so
wondering how a line item would work
for child who comes into a functioning
school district and is part of the the
general population I mean
what you estimate ahead of time what
what you're going to charge for that
child's attendance but uh but in terms
of having an account that you're going
to be
charging costs to a line item that
work I think the talks about estimates
you're
projecting um based upon what uh maybe
the past history uh but uh that is
that's why I open up saying there's that
area right there that I feel that uh how
it's worded makes
it difficult for the sending school to
know or project uh what they're going to
representative Pap Miller thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative lad
for present for introducing the bill and
taking questions on to the um in regards
to the concerns expressed that a um open
enrollment School may receive less
tuition than their costs is there
anything in this bill forcing anybody to
become an open enrollment school no
there's nothing there and when you have
these two these two accounts whether
you're going to have an account for the
kids which you're receiving money for
the students which are enrolled in your
school you're now being asked to write
an account for those which are going to
the receiving
school and the money that that students
going to need is in the other account
right the first account so you're going
to have to take some out of one account
to throw it in another account to cover
what you estimate to be the cost for
sending to the receiving school right
and a quick follow up thank you and in
regards to the very last paragraph that
we were talking about about the
estimating
lines in your reading of the previous
language and new language do you see any
substantial difference between the
current obligations versus the new ones
because frankly I don't see one but I
don't see it either I don't see it
either I I I see it that the money's
going to have to come from the budget
and there's what you got in your
adequacy funds are there and but this is
saying that they want to have have it in
a separate line item which so you have
to split something up thank you how much
I don't
know I wasn't able to find a difference
in the two sentences representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so
um can you speak to the sort of how this
could potentially impact CTE programs
because I know that one of the
challenges uh that sending districts
face in with CTE programs is any class
schedules and
transportation so would this provide
additional opportunities for students
who are interested in Career and
Technical education uh to take full
advantage of those programs it would
certainly help and I think there's
another way that folks are looking at
right now is for the students in that
sending District that wants to get over
here where the CTE program exists to be
enrolled in the program that exists so
that the everything received over here
is now received over here so they become
a student of that school and take all
their general education courses as well
in the school that they're at for CTE so
you don't you're eliminating all the
transportation that's the way it would
there um representative
fellows um yes I'd like to get back to
the the budget question and the listing
something in the budget and so so I want
the fact that the new language says
estimated
expenditure um standard practice for a
business administrator in a school
district is that if they they don't know
um for sure they will have to spend uh
make an expenditure out of a certain
category of expenditures but they might
what they would normally put in the
budget would be
$1 because you can't make an
expenditure into an that's related to an
account that has zero as a budget but if
it says $1 you it can be amended by this
depending on the amount of the money by
um by the school board so to say
estimated expenditure I think um really
creates a problem does does that make
sense to
you quite truthfully I'm having a hard
time understanding between between the
two sentences cuz estimated expenditure
so um I don't
believe yeah well so that doesn't make
any sense either because in your budget
a school district uh you know a business
administrator unless they know that
students are going to go to an open
enrollment school what they would do is
they would put $1 on that budget budget
line because that makes it available to
transfer some funds into that if it
should be needed because if you have a
line that says zero you can't transfer
to that line so I think the
original um language has a problem from
chair any
response no okay representative papich M
it's a very brief comment I just wanted
to say
that this is not an executive session
but I would be happy to talk a lot about
that in the executive session and go
into the details I just don't want to
phrase it as a question here because it
would be unfair at this time so trust me
we can address that thank you
representative mcquire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question who makes the decision how much
money will be sent from the sending
District to the receiving District this
says this is very vague in terms of not
less than
80% I would have to look back
historically how that's been done in
District said the same language exists
in
both this proposed law and the new I
know this is not new that's not new yeah
may I follow up yes
so I'm I'm under the impression that
this is not a a program that's succeeded
because there's only one um open
enrollment School right and and the
danger for a school deciding to be open
enrollment is a district could send them
their most expensive student right a
special ed student with some no he's
shaking his head well the the parent the
parent of this you know whatever student
could send them of a $200,000 student
could decide I'm going to that school
and and as far as I read this the Open
Enrollment school doesn't can't say no
and the other District says well okay
I'll give you your 30 thou you know your
$20,000 or whatever the number if I were
an open enrollment School administrator
or principal and I had an open
enrollment school that was declining in
population but had some wonderful
programs I'd gladly solicit from all the
districts around me and try to draft
their students off and bring them into
my school so I can load it up and I can
sustain my program I wouldn't worry
about what happens on the other side of
the leder but the other school but I I
would I would sell my
competition
okay I guess my question is it seems
that one of the key things being changed
here is to label schools as either
sending or receiving but I don't get the
sense uh that it fully flushes out what
the implications are particularly for
the sending School the receiving school
can elect to receive
but the sending school has no
choice is that am I reading it the way
you understand it if it's an open that's
the way I read it okay yes all right um
are we breaking new
ground and there there are there excuse
me there are people from doe here we
have the department
fine okay representative Fells um yes so
so you just said that right now now it
would make Financial sense for a school
to say that they're open enrollment
school because they have empty seats
that that would be a beneficial
financially if they could fill them but
was that the situation back in
2009 my recollection is that's when
enrollment was very high and there were
there there were schools that you know
they were bursting at the scams they had
so many students you are correct back
then there was about 210,000 students
students in the state now we're down
around 160 and so they had the students
one and I don't know if there was one at
that time but that's when the law came
in effect representative
Dan thank you Mr chair thank you
again so would you comment on the
potential fiscal impact to the sending
District if the number student students
that they're sending to one or more open
enrollment schools if there were
more diminishes the sending District's
student enrollment but not enough for
them to close a classroom or otherwise
reduce costs so they're adding what is
tuition costs to their existing
correct well there there if it's going
to be if they're going to take from one
school to another school with in the
school district they're still going to
have to provide the
transportation going outside the
district they don't have to provide
transportation so there
might if you're going to pay 80% the
other 20% is going to be where it's
going to be left in the district that's
how I see it and you're asking somebody
right here has never done this before as
a in a school so it's probably wise to
ask folks that are more familiar with
open enrollment which I am not familiar
with that
okay I think it's come time to allow the
uh thank you introduce have a good
afternoon all right
um I have three green cards I mean these
are pink
um
anyway
testing uh so I'm GNA call Barett
Christina the New Hampshire school
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
members of the committee bar Christino
executive director of the New Hampshire
school boards Association we are opposed
to the bill um I think what is most
important for this committee to consider
when it's considering House Bill
771 is that there is currently a case
pending before the New Hampshire Supreme
Court relative to what the operations
are um and the obligation of a district
um that has not not adopted the Open
Enrollment statute but yet is having
students for lack of a way of putting it
poached from another school district um
representative lad is correct there's
only one open enrollment sta One open
enrollment school um in the state right
now um there was a matter that um was
appealed to the State Board of Education
the hearings officer had one
interpretation of the statute um the
State Board of Education ignor the
hearings officer's recommendation and
issued its own findings um so that
matter um was filed with the New
Hampshire Supreme Court I believe in it
was either August or October I I have it
here on my notes um before any changes
are made to the open enrollment statute
nsba believes that we should let the
litigation sort of play itself out there
are questions about the main question is
if one school district um authoriz is
authorized by its voters to become an
open enrollment school but a neighboring
School District does not is not an open
enrollment School the voters have not
followed the process in RSA
194d does the district that has not
adopted the open Roman statute have to
pay tuition to the school district in
which those children wish to attend so
that's what's pending and we have one
interpretation of the statute the State
Board of Education had a different
interpre of the statute the attorneys
represent one of the school districts at
issue has an interpretation um so that
matter is pending before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court that needs to be
resolved first um because I I think
there going to be more and more of these
open enrollment schools perhaps coming
forward as we're seeing changes to I'll
just call it school choice for lack of a
better way of putting it but until this
statute is is clarified as to what is
the tuition obligation of a sending
School District that has not authorized
or not adopted the Open Enrollment
statute we think that we should we
should pause any changes to RSA
194d and um I think that's our Prime our
Prime um objection um I do have some
objections relative to the the fiscal
aspect um page two line four excuse me
each district shall establish a line
item in their operating budget on an
annual basis reflecting estimated
expenditures for open enrollment
tuitions that's all well and good if
that school district has adopted the
Open Enrollment provision ision of RSA
194d but if that Pro that that school
district has not adopted the provisions
I don't know why they need to be a line
item in in a particular budget likewise
with all due respect this is generally
local money that's going to be used as
tuition money we don't think the state
should be telling local school districts
what line items they necessarily have to
have as it for things that don't
necessarily relate to adequacy but our
biggest concern is that there's a
pending Supreme Court case nhba does not
believe we should be amending anything
relative to the open rment statute until
we get some sort of clarification from
the courts with that I will try to
answer some questions I don't know the
statute that well thank you I think
you've hit the question I asked uh
previously about whether the sending
School District's hand would be forced
yeah thank you uh okay let's see
representative Earth and then
mner thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you take my question so putting
aside the changes that are being made
here do you have the same concerns with
the law as it exists today thank you
very much uh for the question
representative this the
statute itself I think is unclear in
some places and if the statute were more
clear in some places perhaps the the
litigation that's pending right now
would not have been necessary so um
again to mind I've never worked closely
with this statute again there's only one
other statute or one school District
that has adopted the Open Enrollment
statute I will say this this is my
anecdotal recommendations as well too um
that a number of years ago I want to say
15 maybe more there was another school
district that sought to invoke or become
an open enrollment school um they
received um a legal opinion I believe
from the Department of Education that
was contrary to what the state board
ruled maybe a year or so ago so to your
question representative the statute the
full totality of RSA 194d I think is
unclear in in in some places and
probably could stand for some amendments
moving
forward representative guire thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so I don't understand your your
first point you said there's a Supreme
Court case it's vague we should because
the law is vague uh so we should wait
and see what the Supreme Court says it
really means why don't we do what's
being done here on page one line n and
make it clear or if if that's not enough
you know make it even clearer in other
places that are vague and and have it
really say whatever we want it to say
and and let people not spend their money
at the Supreme Court not wait for the
Supreme Court all that sort of stuff
right thank you for the much question or
for for the question represent yeah I
mean this body can certainly make the
Amendments you know as as it sees fit it
I think the question would be that
you're probably going to get opposing
interpretations of what the statute
should say then or at least opposing
views on what I we get that all the time
too I I'm not saying that's not not a
reason to do it representative but yeah
certainly the the the question the gist
of the question is what are the spending
obligations of a district that has not
adopted open enrollment schools Can a
district that has adopted the Open
Enrollment statute poach students from
another school
district and and and just make the
sending District pay tuition even though
they even though that sending district
has not become an open enrollment School
itself that's the gist of the issue
thank
you representative Ames
yeah I think you're the point is well
taken that we should be as informed as
we can be on this uh issue and um and to
that end we need to understand the
litigation that is directly on point and
it would be really helpful to me in
order to do all of that to have at least
a link to the uh litigation so that uh I
am maybe the others here can uh can read
what the complaint says and what the
response says because that's probably
all there is right now thank you very
much representative I am not in
possession of all those documents I can
reach out to the attorney that's
representing the school district at
issue and see what I can what I what I
can gather and pass along to the
committee one other thing too just if I
may uh Mr chair for the moment I've used
the word poach a couple of times that
may be too strong of a word I don't mean
to imply that there's any wrongdoing
I'll just say um perhaps actively
solicit students from outside the school
district I I don't want to I don't want
to apply any you know negative intent to
that word by chance so I I apologize for
using that word that may be a little bit
a little bit
loaded okay um can I ask our committee
researcher gen for perhaps you can run
that link down for us as representative
Ames asked
could you run down the link to this
pending Supreme Court case I can I can
get in the coming week or so I can get I
can get Miss for the pertinent
information terrific okay next is
representative Amon excuse me Damon and
then Papa each Muller and then I think I
saw
Fells thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Christina does the Schoolboard
Association have any perspective to
share on the broad concept of increasing
the number of open enrollment schools
and thank you very much uh for the
question representative um specifically
no I will say if two school districts
want to become open enrollment schools
and engage in some sort of agreement for
the students then two school districts
are can can can can do that it's not NH
hba's position to because it has being
an open enrollment school has to be
authorized by the voters via warrant
article so you know we don't question
what what voters in a particular
District do if voters in two districts
prerogative representative Pap thank you
Mr chair and nice seeing you again a
pleasure thank you um just a quick
question since you were talking about
the you know soliciting of students my
understanding of the NHS Ba's concern
seems to not be related to whether the
students are solicited or not but simply
to the fact that they are going to
another school district and the you know
sending School District now owes tuition
even though they didn't adopt that do I
understand that correctly or is there a
Nuance there regarding whether the
receiving District solicit students or
they just knock on the door by
themselves right thank you for the
question representative Our concern is
that we believe that the State Board of
Education misinterpreted the statute and
is misapplying the statute um and the
concerns with it our concerns with that
is that the the the the State Board of
the state board's interpretation of the
statute
would have potentially would have
significant ramifications Statewide we
believe that in order for a student to
be to a to in order for a student to be
a sending student to a different School
District under the Open Enrollment
statute the sending District also has to
adopt the Open Enrollment
statute oh quick followup yes I agree I
understand that does it make any
difference whether the rece receiving
District solicits the students or the
students just ask to go there without
any communication yes thank you for the
question repres I mean if the students
ask to go there without their District
being an open Roman school there are
potentially other avenues the best
interest standard under RC 1933 manifest
educational hardship also under RSA 193
colon 3 where the districts could
presumably enter into some sort of
tuition agreement if they wanted thank
you okay do we have further questions
representative fellows right that that
last comment was the answer to my
question very good yeah good to have
that rsay citation yeah okay I think we
have gone the full round thank you very
good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman and committee members I'm David
Trumble from the town aware I have
concerns about the bill and uh confess
to not being an expert on this issue but
hearing from our sponsor who also
admitted it was had some of those same
inabilities to answer I don't feel too
bad um I have three concerns the first
is on the line item issue on page two it
seems to me that this line item now
creates an o obligation for every school
district in the state to be a sending
District because it says each School
District shall establish a lion
reflecting their estimated expenditures
representative fellow said you can't
send any money if you don't have
something already in that line item so
this line item would require at least
$1 this means that the lawsuit that's
before The Supreme Court now which is
based on the question of does a sending
District have to be an open enrollment
District in order to be a sending
District it would eliminate that lawsuit
which might accomplish representative
McGuire's question why by having a
lawsuit but it would through law back
door around the court case and say that
every District in the state must be
ascending
District so whether or not that's a good
idea or bad idea I think that that's the
impact of page two line
four um the second thing I had a concern
about is the addition of the word open
enrollment program which nobody has
discussed yet but one of the things that
concerns me is that uh with online
education that you could very well have
a school that sets up itself as an
online
program we have vac in every single town
in the state it's a great program what
makes it so good is that there can only
be so many students per teacher There's
an actual teacher behind that wall um I
don't want to litigate the prageru thing
that we went through last year but just
to point out a comparison of three
different scenarios you you passed the
law that said every school has to have a
financial literacy course for half a
credit at that time I went back and did
research every school high school in the
state has a financial literacy course
now the typical course is about 75 hours
of classroom time with a teacher
homework assignments and that sort of
thing the VX course which I couldn't get
into because you have to pay money to
actually see the whole curriculum which
you can see the outline of the course
there was 18 lessons it would probably
be about the same amount of time and
there would be a person and there would
be homework assignment so whether you
went to your local high school and got
it or you got it through VX it would be
a reasonable
alternative the Prager program was 15
videos that were 5 minutes each so
that's a total of 75 minutes and the
test was 30 multiple choice questions at
the end of it so and that got approved
by the State Board of Education so in
other words if in if your child doesn't
want to go to your local high school and
spend 75 hours on financial literacy
with a classroom teacher and homework if
you don't want to go to VX and spend 70
hours with a real life teacher behind
the wall and do all the homework you can
just watch 75 minutes worth of videos
and take a few multiple choice questions
so now the the the rule has been
established in the state that 75 hours
can be replaced with 75 minutes so an
hour in the classroom can be replaced
with one minute of video if some school
sets up an online video program you
could basically just have a whole and
they become somehow a
school it it opens up a door that I
don't think we we really want to go to
you can have the kids stay in their
local school if they want to take a
couple classes through V like if your
child wants European history your high
school doesn't have it they can take
that extra course through VX but this
addition of the word program has not
been Justified there's been no
explanation of what it's here for what
it could do but I do see potential
problems with it and the third concern
I've got is just with the Open
Enrollment notion in general I I I think
it's great that children should have
choice but I think there should only be
choice if every child also has a chance
to get a good education until as a state
we provide a chance for every child I
don't think we want to expand the choice
opportunities what makes New Hampshire
unique in the financial sector is that
we are last in state spending in the
United States now Michigan I was just
listening to a man from Michigan give a
talk about their open enrollment program
out there and and he pointed out that
pretty much out there all the schools
well funded and the US Census Data I
I'll turn it into you shows the federal
state and local sources for each state
in America in Michigan they pay 55% in
New Hampshire we pay 27% this is the
latest from the US Census they're paying
twice as much from the state that means
that every single school out there every
child's got a reasonable chance in New
Hampshire you have huge disparities in
spending between town that results in
huge disparities in proficiency between
town just to give you some examples I
know there there's some legislators here
who have Newport and Charlestown in your
District those schools have 10%
proficiency that means out of levels 1 2
3 and four levels three and four is
proficient 10% are proficient Bedford on
the other hand is 69 hopkington is 61
conquer is 54 my hometown aware is 22%
when you have more money you get higher
proficiency when you have less you get
lower proficiency so I think until we
actually spend money and make sure that
every child has a chance to get a good
education it's would be inappropriate
for the state to expand Choice programs
which will exacerbate the differences
between the Haves and Have Nots you look
at this here and it would be available
if if a parent wants to exp make no if
you make every school in the state be
open enrollment if basically this this
this this law would create Statewide
open enrollment those who can afford to
transport their child to another
District would automatically have a
right to go there so if you're in
Newport and you want your child to go to
cipy which is just next door New London
which is really next door in the other
direction or you're in Charles toown and
you want to go to one of these towns or
Claremont you could easily make that
happen under this statute but what that
does is it creates the difference we
have between the halves and half not as
unconscionable right now this would
exacerbate that difference difference
first let's fund every school give every
child in the state a fair chance and
then you probably won't need to have a
lot of people who want to go open
enrollment because their Hometown school
would be adequate this just exacerbates
an existing problem and I'm sorry one
more thing which is all the other
options in the status quo that exists
like Mr lad representative lad said you
have CTE that are different one town is
the Alvine is the agricultural School
other town is the automotive School you
that already exists in the Pres system
if you have a problem you can go through
manifest hardship if you have a problem
you can get your child tuition to
another school if both sides agree to it
you can solve these problems right now
we with the voluntary open enrollment
system this bill I think on page two
would make it mandatory that every
school in the state become an open
enrollment school both ways or certainly
at least sending thank
questions okay see none thank you very
much for your
sorry about
that my name is Timothy Robinson I'm a
resident of Pittsfield um I'm on the
Pittsfield school board I am not
representing the school board of the seu
I'm representing myself uh just so we're
aware that affiliation wise um I have
lots of concerns about uh RSA 194d
obviously Pittsfield is a party to
what's going on Supreme Court um I will
say that the concept or the vision of
school choice is a great idea right so
that if it was a a school that was more
centered on music a kid could go there
if there was more centered on History
the kid could go there great concept the
the the mapping of how we get from here
to there under RSA 9 194 is not fair to
taxpayers and it's not fair to the
people that with the amount of money
that local money that's spent on school
budgets it it's not fair to them it's
always the devil's always in the details
right so the details here on what's
being presented here is it's almost the
as with what has happened with the
opinion from the doe where certain
language was cherry-picked in my opinion
um and it was excised out of if you read
the three words before it would change
the meaning that's what I mean it was
Cherry Picked in their decision um again
my opinion not anybody else's said to
create an environment where you were
forcing sending districts to pay money
uh the language in this proposed uh in
House Bill
771 um kind of only reinforces that so
if you go down to on 194 D colon 5 uh
section one uh with with the addition of
the word receiving School uh that
doesn't that it kind of requires the uh
the sending school and this receiving
school it requires sending District to
have to actually pay there's no you know
there's there's other language in the
RSA that talks about adoption of the the
legislation and that that has never
occurred in Pittsfield nobody's ever
voted to send students outside of the
district even though we've been sent a
bill to pay for and that's why we're
where we're at um to get to an open
enrollment school but the the the voters
and the taxpayers in Pittsfield have
never discussed this and never voted on
it but um we got a state agency that's
essentially requiring us you know under
their opinion to pay for tuition for
student that the the taxpayers voters of
Pittsfield never voted to do it's a
program that that does that uh I have if
I if more of this was the pass uh the
language 80% of the sending districts
average um I understand you know that's
if we had a really high T you tuition
that they would get up to 80% of that if
their tuition was that there's no cap on
it what on the TW on the receiving
schools tuition in proportion to the
sending schools uh per student cost if
you're going to do one I think you got
to do both right I'm not even I don't
support the legislation but if you're
going to look at this legislation and
you're going to do this we have to do
the the the sending District you know
some some there has to be some cost
control and some some ability to to cap
that on on that and I know won't be 100%
you know because it's some some of these
programs might be way more expensive but
it has to be capped in some kind of per
way way that's in line with what the
average cost per student is at the at
the at the district um I I just when
when this happened in Pittsfield as a
resident Pittsfield I I felt that this
is like a slippery slope right so the
way this happened you know member of the
community decid to send their kids to
another school which is you know that
that can happen in in everywhere else it
kind of happens they pay the they pay
the twit themselves right you know
currently if if they're not part of this
enrollment program there's near no
difference than if I called uh a private
Paving Company and asked them to PVE in
front of my house and told them to send
the bill to town of Pittsfield in
reality there's no difference that's
exactly what happened on this this just
happen to be uh a student going to a
different school you know and the town's
been asked to or the the taxpayers has
been asked to pay for it so I feel like
it just opens up this really weird
environment where those of us who are
paying local property taxes don't have
control over the expenses and I think
you know having been on the board I mean
trust me there's a lot
more um transparency with people looking
at even to how much we spend on copy
paper you know at the local school
district you know in as opposed to just
getting a tuition bill from another
school so we the the the people who in
the receive in the sending district will
lose that Fidelity and the ability to
cap those costs
you know whether the costs are
reasonable or not it would also lose the
ability to change out the elected
representatives on the board if they
don't like the direction the school's
going and there's a lot you know in the
local school district now that you have
the ability to change out the board
members if you don't like it who then
can maybe you know set new policy and
direction for that school district if we
get forced to start paying tuition to to
to schools that we don't have any
control over we lose control over that
town the individual choices they make
and we get stuck with the bill and we
have no ability to to have any kind of
say on that bill other than requir the
way this legislation is currently
written to just pay the bill and I don't
think that's fair to the taxpayers in
any District in the in the state I I you
know I'm only speaking from my view from
Pittsfield obviously you know we're a
very small school and losing money out
of the district is is a probably a
larger impact than this to some of the
bigger districts in in the state
but it still we still lose that kind of
concept of the New England town meeting
local control um the with this
particular legislation the way it is uh
open up to any questions from from
Members sure if I could start just
reading between the lines and to to
clarify am I understanding you correctly
that pittsfield's school district is
involved in the pending Supreme Court
legation yes it is sir thank you and in
that case I also don't I think we've
been told what's the
one um school that has adopted open
enrollment it's the Alton School
District and that's the one you're
dealing with correct yeah okay
questions all right very informative
thank you very much thank you thank you
for your
talk okay I don't have any more pink
cards is there anybody who'd like to
address the
bill good we're all set and uh I'm going
e
okay we're going to go ahead head with
the next hearing which we
have the next bill is HB
665 relative to eligibility for free
School
meals repent the hall you're here
welcome
you're welcome to give us testimony in
this
one I'm back you're
back thank you good afternoon chairman
lad members of the education funding
committee
for the record I'm Uriel Hall and I
represent the fine people of bow and
hoofington District 9 as well as all
Granite Staters I'm here this afternoon
to introduce House Bill 665 which
increases the eligibility for free
School meals to household incomes up to
300% of federal poverty guidelines
feating more kids at school is at the
heart of this legislation we have too
many kids who go to school hungry with
minimal or little access to food most of
us don't like to go hungry yesterday the
snow storm was brewing folks were
anxious about their commute we could
have worked our way through the
remaining bills and gotten out maybe at
1:30 but we stopped for a lunch break
because folks were hungry some kids
don't have that luxury to just go just
go eat when they're hungry in the fall
of 2023 a study commission a study
committee was established it had three
Senators three Representatives four of
those Republicans and two Democrats two
of you or one of you in this room right
now on that committee one of the tasks
of that statutory committee was
determine if the income eligibility
relative to free School meals should be
expanded the final report submitted by
the Republican chair of the committee
noted that one the majority of the
committee recommended that a bill should
be filed this term to increase free and
reduced eligible eligible students from
185 to 200% of poverty the minority
recommended the increase be three 100%
of poverty which is reflected in this
bill that I'm introducing
today the majority report regarding that
eligibility expansion to 200% stated
that it was crystal clear in the
committee that the cost of the current
High inflation is hitting low-income
families the hardest and increasing food
insecurity in many of our citizens homes
current eligibility leaves a large
portion of students who are financially
V vulnerable without access to meals
this recommended incremental change to
cover the cost for food only would go a
long way to improving the educational
setting so that no student is sitting at
a desk trying to learn while hungry
again that was a majority report The
Minority Report noted that 300% increase
would ensure that more children have
access to the nutrition that they need
to reach their full potential access to
nutritious meals improve student health
mental and physical and the increase
would provide greatest stability for
those in need allowing them to focus
more on their studies and less on
worrying about where their next meal
would come from it's important to note
that this bipartisan committee as a
whole agreed that the income eligibility
relative to free School meals should be
expanded I hope we can all agree that
food is essential to learning and that
all students deserve an equal
opportunity to learn and that food
insecurity puts tremendous stress on
families who are struggling to hit their
basic needs budgets given the increased
cost of food as well as Child Care
Health Care Transportation housing
utilities you know a lot you know we
heard a lot about the price of eggs I
bought a dozen eggs the other day for
$6.99 and they weren't cagefree our
neighbors of Maine Vermont and
Massachusetts have all implemented
healthy School meals for
all according to the doe fiscal note
this bill would ensure that half of our
student population the more vulnerable
population had access to school meals
um and with that I'll take questions
knowing the folks behind me I'll be more
equipped to answer them especially
questions about the financial input
please vote art to pass on House Bill
665 our children deserve
it thank you very much representative
Hall yes representative bricky this is
just a question thank you for it's a
question not so much for representative
there is there an updated fiscal note
the last I have the only one I have came
out
11025 yes
2325 so for some reason not all of us
got the 2325 ones that came out who who
has who does not have this amendment one
two three same
three oh four five six uh Jennifer do
you think we could get some copies of
that M Jennifer it's right here
I didn't have it Tony did I really
didn't have
it thank you any further questions for
representative Hall yes representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
this bill affects those whose household
income is between 185% and
300% of federal poverty guidelines what
fraction of children in that from those
households are malnourished and what
would be the source of that
data I would thank you for your question
I would refer that to hunger solutions
they would be better to answer that
question in terms of the data thank you
further questions from the committee yes
represent spillsbury then representative
papovich so in line 16 it says the
amount necessary to fund this paragraph
is hereby appropriated I don't think we
normally just appropriate whatever it
costs is the is there an estimate and a
figure that you would like to see
appropriated would be the cost whatever
it costs whatever it
costs okay represent papovich thank you
Mr chair and thank you for introducing
the bill and testifying you stated in
your testimony that this money is only
to feed the kids are you saying that the
legal
language removes the connection between
the uh free and elig students eligible
for free and reduced meals and the
school fund funding in the left side of
the funding
formula would you ask that question
again sure you testified that the only
money this bill is asking for is the
money needed to feed the children I'm
asking you whether the language
specifically removes the connection
between the number of kids that are
eligible for free and reduced meals and
the additional school funding for
Education we provide in the left side of
the funding formula yeah I I'm going to
let someone else answer that question
thank you further
questions not seeing thank you very much
Horgan I'm representing Timothy Oregon
for straford County District 10 the town
of Durham and um so I support this bill
I've uh co-sponsored or sponsored
similar bills in the past um in this
case this case they ran out of room on
the Mast head so I was eager to be on it
myself but I let others be on it and I
just say I support this bill um and I
was glad you had the discussion about
the the fiscal note because the copy
that I grabbed that's on the table the
Department of Education hadn't provided
the fiscal note yet but um that was just
11025 but the updated one is on the
website and so so I have a little bit
more you know I was about to make a
cynical comment about why they didn't
have a fiscal note but they did a good
fiscal note so the bill that's before
you I guess they say it would cost about
48 million that's uh for feeding
children I think that's a very good
cause and it uh it saves the and it
saves the uh the parents of the kids uh
48 collectively 48 million because they
or probably more than 48 million because
reduces the transaction cost of
collecting of uh of paying for those
meals that's money it goes back in the
pockets of working young Working
Families and that's I think that's a
good thing that's a very good investment
48 million and
um looks like uh if you want to go even
further if you want to give every sounds
like uh if you take that 48 million that
would applied about 50% of the school
population so we double that it's 96
million so that's uh maybe not in this
particular budget cycle but I think
that's a that's probably an achievable
goal especially given that it say you're
feeding children and you're also uh
freeing up that money for uh for use by
the the growing families that those
children belong to and I might also
point out that like no matter how
affluent the parents may or may not be
school children are children so they
basically don't have any most of them
don't have any money of their own unless
you're like the 12-year-old kid who
shovels out my driveway who makes $40
per snowstorm but he he's he's a very
rare rare kid most kids do not have any
money of their own so they you know
regardless of the congressman he said he
had a job and worked his way through
High School well that's U that's now how
it how it is for for the vast majority
of kids they don't have any money even
the ones who are working are saving up
to go to college or do other things in
our later life so I would just I would
just say this is a good bill even with
the budget circumstances we can afford
it and uh we should pass it and also
emphasize another question the way this
is written it doesn't affect the whole
distinction between free and reduced uh
families for uh which is deeply embedded
in our school funding system and maybe
our school funding system doesn't work
but you won't be able to change it
between now and uh now and the end of
this session so we may as well stick
with the framework we have so so please
pass this bill and if anything I'd be
happy if you made it even more inclusive
so thanks thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee not see thank you very much
thank you uh I'd like to call nassy
vongh
sorry for the delay I just wanted to
pass out my written testimony to the
committee um for the record um I am
Nancy vaugh government relations
director for the American Heart
Association here in New Hampshire um and
I am here um in support of House Bill
665 um cardiovascular disease is a
leading cause of death and health care
costs in the United States the American
Heart Association has been working um to
uh to help children grow up at a healthy
weight so that they could live longer
and healthier lives students having
access to nutritious School meals will
improve their health and Readiness to
learn food and nutrition security and
scho attendance during childhood are
predictive of health and productivity
into
adulthood with House Bill 665 we have an
opportunity to ensure students in New
Hampshire are set up to succeed by
increasing eligibility for healthy noost
School meals we are providing an
important tool in academic success and
helping children develop a lifetime
habit of consuming foods that support
good health while the USDA School Meal
program has provided critical access to
healthy meals to thousands of New
Hampshire children annually through the
free reduced price School breakfast and
lunches there are still students of
families just above the income
eligibility threshold that come to
school hungry and are unable to purchase
a school breakfast or lunch as a result
of families trying to get by with
increased food
prices and other costs of living
expenses there's also the issue of
unpaid School Meal debt causing a
financial strain on local school
districts this bill seeks to increase
the income eligibility level for for
meals at no cost to the child's family
working towards closing the gap for low
and moderate income families this will
eliminate the reduced price category
greatly reduces if not eliminates the
problem of school meal debt and
streamlines the school um Food Service
program I have um cited um some studies
and reports in my uh my testimony um you
know to combat food insecurity one of
the very important benefits of this bill
it was found food insufficiency dropped
by 14% among students who participate in
the national school lunch program
students from food insecure and
marginally secure households get more of
their food and nutrients from school
meals than other students it promotes
good nutrition students who eat school
lunches tend to take in more whole
grains vegetables and dairy and fewer
refined sugars and empty caral calories
ensuring academic success students who
have nutritious diets tend to perform
better and pay more attention in school
and strengthening School budgets
increased access to free meals will
eliminate unpaid School Meal debt which
is an issue that's been a subject of
another bill um that's come before the
legislature this year in closing um I
did not know about the um uh updated
fiscal note on this bill so um the
dollar amount I'm about to uh to share
with you is not from that um but I have
a Funding Solution for House Bill 665
it's in the hands of the house Ways and
Means Committee there's another bill
House Bill 290 which seeks to raise the
state cigarette tax and the tax on
ecigarettes all the revenue from this
increase expected to be $49.5 million in
its first year will go into the
education trust fund and could fund the
cost of House Bill 665 I urge you to
pass this bill and work with your
legislative colleagues and house Ways
and Means on the other Bill to secure
the funds needed to feed more children
in school and please consider me a
resource for you on this bill and other
policies related to heart health um
you'll see that I've also attached um a
recent report from the New Hampshire
fiscal policy Institute um which um has
a lot of great information well not
great information because we don't want
to have to see this um but it um it
really outlines um the cost of living in
New Hampshire and poverty in New
Hampshire and I'm happy to take any
questions and answer them to the best of
my ability thank thank you very much are
are there any questions for Miss
Von yes representa
coom thank you chairman L and thank you
for taking my question um I'm looking at
a at a random uh menu here from a school
do you think that providing our kids
with cinnamon roll for breakfast is a
heart healthy breakfast or in today's
breakfast it was a whole grain baked dut
is that a heart healthy breakfast that
our kids should be eating before they're
being educated I I do have to say that I
am not a nutritionist um and um I'm not
sure which school it is um and whether
they're part of the um USDA um School
meals program but they do need to follow
guidelines so I don't know what is in
the um in the uh the recipe for those
items but it may as long as it's in line
with the uh the fats and sugars and
sodiums that are recommended for young
children then yes it's
further questions from the committee
represent
Amon I permission to augment that
response well no I'd like to I know
you're a
nutritionist um let's not let's just ask
questions if you have a question ask a
question so Miss
B would you be able to
confirm
that would you be able ble to confirm
that the school lunch program well two
parts so that most New Hampshire schools
do participate in the federal school
lunch program yes and so if
we um
believe that school referenced is part
of that
program thank
you would you be able to confirm that
the federal standards for the school
lunch program are very specific to the
nutrition composition of foods such that
a for instance cinnamon roll is probably
a much much healthier food than what all
of us are salivating for right now or
many of us as in less fat more whole
grain less sugar Etc to the best of my
limited abilities as as a non-
nutritionist I would agree with you that
the US um da um food standards need to
be in line with um with what is um
developed for for the health of
children any further questions not
seeing it thank you very much thank you
Mr chair yes if I may just a question I
want to make sure that I it's
appropriate to do this it's not for you
I apologize your off um one of the
previous testimonies mentioned they
joined the Senate U house committee that
was established that I was a member of
would it be appropriate since that
committee was mentioned for me to
forward the final report of that
committee to our committee researcher so
she can distribute it to everybody on
the committee please let's discuss that
following this meeting okay yes sir yeah
cor thank you chairman lad goodon riona
core New Hampshire hunger Solutions I
actually have a Bachelor of Science I am
a clinic nutritionist as well for the
last 10 to 15 years I worked in the wick
may I adjust the questions to previously
that there was no answers to you you
have four right now so so the cinnamon
rolls that you did State they are 50% or
more whole grains they are either with
the food Management program and they're
very strict on those vitamins and
minerals that are fortified with they're
actually iron rich with and with the
same brand of the cine minis
specifically that are bought in Hanford
Shaw's Walmart you cannot buy these in
the store so even if it is Pillsbury
they are 50% or more with vitamin
enriched there's a little bit of more
protein and iron and and less sodium as
well and representative uh
papichi you did mention about the uh
funding formula the funding formula will
not be changed for this because they use
the federal um guidelines so I do want
to State those prior so thank you so my
name is riona core I am New Hampshire
hunger Solutions deputy director um I
also oversee all the Child Nutrition
work I work with schools directly across
the state of New Hampshire I did State
previously in this committee 40 schools
I signed on two more schools after
testifying last week so I have 42
schools that I work with directly Food
Service Management Programs as well I
work with business administrators my
main goal with the schools is to
increase the free and reduce
applications increase snap enrollment
and try to get the school budgets um
appropriate
within the schools themselves by doing
that we like to increase the breakfast
participation in September 2024 the US
Census stated in New Hampshire 39% of
children lived in households reporting
not having enough food the New Hampshire
Food Bank testified on this committee
last week that they distributed an
increase of a million pounds of food
over 17 million pounds and it was still
not enough to meet the New Hampshire's
needs when we think of individuals in
New Hampshire receiving food charitable
sites help
programs um across the state I want to
just address this one item even though
the children's stomach is full it
doesn't mean that their cells um have
the adequate nutrition to
succeed I can tell you that the belly of
a child could be full of a poptart that
they're receiving from aable food but
their cells are not getting enough
adequate nutrition to grow and to learn
the school meals are designed to have
the correct nutrition they're vitamin
rich fortified the H more protein the
fruits and vegetables served within the
schools there's they reach half the
requirement per day for adequate growth
it's very strict with USDA regulations
and state regulations in it in 2025 they
just changed the sodium level again to
reduce that in children and School meals
since the school meals are adequately
healthy the research states that those
who eat the meals at school are more
likely to graduate have better grades
they also have less behavior problems
attendance Nancy Von did mention the
fiscal policy Institute um I have a I
believe we handed that out as well in it
stated in 2024 a family of three needed
97,7 annually to have enough money for
living expenses that's all the
expenses currently for free meals right
now in New Hampshire a family three um
34,653 and reduced
meals this bill would reduce
Administration burden at the schools and
lower the amount of school meal debt
within the schools and that School Meal
debt is AC Creed because those
individuals do not qualify for the free
and reduced meals but cannot afford um
for their family to have those children
eat food at
school specifically the conquered School
District had an alltime high of over
$90,000 of school meal debt when talking
with the business administrator and the
food service director over there
currently they're over 53,000 $53,000 of
school meal debt as of
today the school sees this as a need in
supporting those families who are making
more than $35,000 annually and less than
that $97,000 annually for household
expense of the fiscal policy Institute
stated there's a lot of people falling
through the cracks and it's not only
dual income families they're single
families and there's an all-time high of
kinship families out there grandparents
taking care of their grandchildren in
New
Hampshire we did have a reference chart
that we handed out for the fiscal note
and I am open to taking any questions
thank you very much are there questions
from the
committee not seeing yes represent
papovich thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you for providing the
presentation I'm sure my question will
come as no surprise to you um you you
stated that there is a certain
percentage of people reported as not
having enough food I don't remember I I
could you repeat that percentage US
Census pulse data it's 39% 39 and my
question is are those do those people
lack enough food or is the definition of
food insecurity that is used to get that
information brought and it includes
people that have enough food at this
time but may worry about future food
availability thank you for your question
so the US Census it is subjective to the
individual who's who's answering the
question so not having enough food in
general um I would state that they had
to search Elsewhere for other food
sources such as charitable food
donations or other sources thank you
further
questions thank you very much thank you
applebe Mike appleberg okay with bad
handwriting um so my name is Mike
appleberg I'm president of United wave
of Greater nashaa and we I'm here
representing our organization in support
of HB 665 increasing access to free
School meals for families up to 300% of
the federal poverty level for us this
bill represents a crucial step ensuring
that no child in New Hampshire goes
hungry at school simply because their
family earns slightly too much money to
qualify for
assistance to put some numbers on it and
a little bit to representative McGuire
Maguire's earlier question about Hunger
um right now a family of four four
people must earn less than $39,000 to
qualify for free School meals and no
more than
$55,000 to R receive reduced price meals
HB 665 would raise that limit to $90,000
Rec Rec recognizing that many Working
Families do struggle to afford basic
necessities despite not meeting these
very low thresholds in NASA alone the
effect would be significant currently
over, 1500 students receive reduced
price meals
meaning their families still have to pay
for food out of pocket under this bill
these students would move automatically
into the reduce price the free category
ensuring that every child who gets who
needs a meal will get a meal without
barriers and without
stigma additionally other other families
earning between 185% and
300% Who currently receive no meal
assistance will finally get the support
they need in our community to ensure
that they children are wellfed at school
we know that hunger affects learning we
all know that studies show that
well-nourished students perform better
academically attend school more
regularly and have fewer disciplinary
issues the benefits extend far beyond
the classroom studies show that for
every $1 invested in school meal
programs there is a return of up to $7
in economic benefits including higher
graduation rates better long-term
earning earning potential and lower
health care costs HB 665 is a modest
investment with a major return
especially because much of the school
funding already comes from federal
sources thus reducing the burden on our
state budget for Nasha families this
bill would eliminate a major financial
burden many parents work hard already to
support their children but they struggle
to afford not just the rising cost of
food but also Child Care housing and
Medical Care
at United Way We believe no child should
have to learn on an empty stomach HB 665
for us is common sense um and helps to
ensure that every child has what they
need to learn I urge you to support and
pass HB 665 and I welcome any questions
thank you are there any questions yes
representative papovich thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here and
testifying I have a very short question
because it's already late in the day of
course um could you tell me since you do
work with a lot of families and kids
that are dealing with you know food
insecurity issues are you familiar with
situations in which school kids go to
you know the lunch counter and are
denied a
meal um denied a meal not per se our
school district and our food services
director is very clear in her mandate to
feed our children that said many
children will
not go to get a meal because they don't
want the stigma of having to incur incur
debt there is definitely an issue around
that so they might self choose not to go
get that meal but being absolutely like
sort of outright denied that's not going
to be the case we have a program um in
nashwa called meals matter which is a
student Le initiative that has raised
pretty significant funds to help pay for
some of the student that that has come
about as a result of uh people who are
in the reduced price category not being
able to actually pay off that lunch debt
and they've helped to supplant that so
uh yes and no thank you so much I
appreciate it absolutely of course yes
representative thank you um and it was
sort of touched on before um by the uh
testimony from New Hampshire hunger
Solutions but can you talk a little bit
maybe about the differ
between um a sun butter sandwich versus
a meal um under this program and what
the nutritional and and I don't know if
you're able to speak to that um but the
nutritional difference between those two
things and the fact that one might be
solving the immediate hunger issue um
but is certainly not addressing adequate
nutrition yeah I am absolutely not not a
nutrition expert I will tell you I have
eaten sun butter and I do on a regular
basis personally but that's just me
personally I do know anecdotally that um
you know there's there's reasons for
that that have also to do with allergies
and allergens in the classroom but I
can't I can't qu qualify that I my
understanding is that a sun butter
sandwich is actually very healthy it's
just not necessarily the thing that's
desired I don't know if that answers
your question thank you further
questions thank you very much thank you
I have some written testimony I'll pass
up to you as well oh there was one
represent crean go ahead thank you sorry
no I just want to make clear our in
you're from nsha yes so when a child um
if there is debt owed and he's not able
to get a meal are you saying in nashille
do that they will give them a regular
meal or are they supplementing with a p
butter or a sun butter sandwich I think
it depends on the school and the grade
level um there I know that there are
different approaches in the elementary
schools and there are in the middle and
high schools I just know from speaking
directly with our food services director
and knowing her pretty well for the past
six or seven years she's got it she and
her staff have a pretty clear mandate
that their job is to feed kids um they
worry about lunch debt that accumulates
I know that the attempt that our muls
matter program um put in place was sort
of a voucher type program so kids could
access food when they you know they
could choose to do that that didn't
really work because kids felt really
uncomfortable asking for you know a
voucher because it would kind of call
them out um I I I do not know specific
instances where they're denied food
though they will encumber debt though
thank you further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
Burke good afternoon chairman lad and
members of the committee thanks for
having this important hearing my name is
Joanne Burke I live in New Market as a
mother
a health professional and a former
nutrition professional at the University
of New Hampshire I come before you with
6665 um you know there has been a
question about the data what does the
data show well nationally um we do have
data from the economic benefits of um
Child Nutrition report of
2024 showing that it uh good nutrition
in school improve Children's Health
well-being and during childhood and that
that predicts better outcomes as adults
and E economic achievement and um
academic achievement in the
2021 The Rocker Feller Foundation which
has far more money than we do to do
these kinds of studies and the center
for good food
purchasing showed that on the average
School meals um could cost around 40
billion
but it exceeds far more the um no I'm
sorry on the average um School Meal
programs
um have economic benefits that far
exceed when we look at the health care
cost associated with inadequate
nutrition so when we think of investing
in our children and the child's capital
and during this hearing people have said
well what about some of the foods being
offered and it is true it can be
confusing because a very similar brand
offered at the school has to meet higher
standards I wish that would be happening
at the hords so I though I admit
confusion those particular products are
designed for school Food Service to meet
those CR criteria and if the the main
part is to to look at this poverty level
because I based it on for a family of
three um and the federal poverty level
is by household size so that doesn't
count that you might be a single parent
and have child care costs so the federal
poverty level we know is artificially
low um it is not a get by level it does
not mean if you are above the federal
poverty level you can afford to live
adequately so the
HHS first box on the handout shows the
around 80,000 for a family of three to
get by in New Hampshire using the
federal poverty level if we go to
nationally recognized organizations that
are updating um regularly the MIT
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
cost to living for the State of New
Hampshire has it at almost 20,000 more
so at 300% of poverty we are not being
frivolous we are helping families who
are working being able to have those
that money that they may have spent on
trying to put together a school lunch to
pay for housing groceries Etc the um
Economic Policy Institute has similar
numbers I will say I had to average
nashwa and Manchester they don't do the
state of New Hampshire so I did take the
two largest communities there
so I know that chairman lad worked as a
school principal and as a teacher knows
that hungry children and hungry adults
have a hard time concentrating in
learning and we are making it easier for
the children for the for the school
staff that are trying to manage school
debt and for the parents and Care
caregivers by providing school lunch and
breakfast at the 300% of poverty level I
would like to see you know Universal
meals for all but
300% surely helps those Working Families
in New Hampshire as a good start so
please vote in favor of
665 I thank you for the work you do on
behalf of children their families and
our communities and I'm open for
questions thank you very much for coming
are there any questions yes
representative Burton I'm not sure you
can answer this question but I want been
wanting to ask it all along um I'm
painfully aware of the need for proper
food for children with type 1
diabetes um they have to balance insulin
exercise and food is
there in the school in this program and
other programs are they accounted for
somehow uh you know I really do believe
so because we do have registered
dietitians and access to that kind of
support so um a a child child um would
the school will be able to work with
that child so surely um if they are
known they that the school meals could
easily meet these requirements but
thanks for asking that just quick follow
one uh thank you thank you Mr chairman
then then this program would benefit
those students who who might not get
enough of the right Foods absolutely I
mean you bring up a really good point
what we find and this happens with
adults who have died diabetes if when
food is insecure they start cutting back
on food but they may be taking their
medicine at the same level and you run
the risk of hypoglycemia so we we know
nationally that the last eight days of
um food assistance from the snap program
there's much more of an incident of
hypoglycemia out of Kaiser Permanente so
this makes sense and a really good um
point to be made thank you further
further questions from the committee yes
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question do you know the
answer to my earlier question about uh
what fraction of um children from this
set of households are
malnourished we don't we don't routinely
I mean right now the state of New
Hampshire no longer even takes Heights
and weights because of a lot of
different reasons but I can assure you
that with you know when you look at the
house of costing of of housing what was
100,000 to buy a house in 1980 is now
close to 500,000 so what I'm saying is
at this
79,000 it is hard on that federal
poverty level for even that group to buy
nutritious food because if you look at
the MIT and the Epi data it's at least
20,000 more so the risk is if any of us
know what it's like with hungry kids if
you're short on a budget are you going
to buy oranges or a bigger bag of potato
chips that goes further so more
nutritious food costs more money we saw
in covid when's children had adequate
meal those dollars that families had
rippled through the economy these are
not people that are sending their
dollars to invest overseas these are
people that generate the funds that were
mentioned earlier that now get their car
fixed or they um go go get a dentist
appointment Etc so though we as a state
don't invest in I mean it's hard work to
do you got to follow kids over time but
nationally we know that kids health is
less robust the lower the income and the
data here surely shows the this level is
representative of families struggling to
get by because it's it's not even what
we acknowledge is probably the real cost
of of
thriving yes thank you so you just said
that um when income level is
lower um kids health is nutrition is
worse right typically it typically I
mean nationally yeah yeah so so but
specifically this food program exists
all over the
nation right
so the school lunch does but there's a
big gap between school lunch who
qualifies for that there are many
children and it's the Working Poor that
get really in between that we don't have
data we can look a kid done school lunch
and participation and they're doing
better than the kid whose parents make
$200 more than the current federal cut
offs so I would posit that it is the
working class person and family and
household who makes too much to
participate we have data a food research
Action Center I'm sure hunger Solutions
can provide you that School meals make a
critical difference where we don't have
as good a data is that monkey in the
middle the kid who says I'm not going to
be embarrassed I'm not going to get in
line they they're going to give me a
different looking lunch and sometimes
that happens sometimes times it doesn't
but it doesn't take long for a child
particularly you see the numbers go off
as they get older to avoid
shaming ma'am one more so specifically
what I'm getting at is
um the programs start at zero and go to
some level right this 1 185% of poverty
and presumably that's similar in other
states and so the argument is that those
in the program do better than those not
right so the ones from 185 to 300 so
there should be data that's that's broad
right for for the whole country even
that that children in this lower level
are better uh have better nutrition than
those just above it they have better
nutrition for what they're eating at
school
not all of those families will be snap
eligible the reality is in America we
have hunger rates that look like a third
world country the school offers an easy
way to address bigger questions right
like why are women in our state making
77 cents on the dollar compared to men
Inc comparable jobs but we can't figure
that out right now in this hearing but
what we can do in in institutions that
currently exist such as schools help to
manage that Gap and help to address as a
community where that is where families
are
congregating it is a simple coste
effective way and the the meals that we
provide through school lunch and
breakfast are far different than what
your local Pantry can give that may or
may not have a refrigerator that may
have limited hours per family
so you're right it would be great if we
had data about every demographic we
don't but we do know of the group we
study and this has actually been a
debate in my nutrition field this comes
up to be quite honest I I brought it up
at a national meeting 16 months ago that
we don't have good data on this fairy
group that you're asking about but it
makes if it walks like a duck talks like
a duck probably a duck makes common
sense that these families are resource
constrained even at
300% and the one place that people feel
they can try to manage they're not going
to get bounced out of their house if
they don't feed their kids well enough
they will get bounced off if they don't
come up with the rent and they need to
put gas in their car to go to work so
food is sort of that luxury item and the
meanwhile the kids
suffer thank you thank you very much are
there further
questions yes thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um I
think you've said a couple of times now
that the food that the kids are getting
in school has is nutrition packed um and
so my question on that is when I look at
a menu item that says cheesy bites
marinara and Scooby-Doo graham crackers
right are you telling me that they're
buying this at a specific food source
are all of our schools in New Hampshire
buying this at from a specific food
source that they they whatever food
source I'm not a school food service
director but if the school is purchasing
it through the federal food food
nutrition program that item has to meet
criteria would I like to see the the
meals even more nutritious yes but the
vendor has to meet sodium and fat
requirements there's a whole list for
school Food Service directors of what
they can purchase
so it could be a vendor so that you have
to meet the criteria so it's not just
they meeting criteria and protein and
carbs also in addition to sodium yes
thank you yes thank you very much are
there further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much thank you so much appreciate this
and all the work you do you're more than
okay good afternoon chairman lad members
of the House Education funding committee
uh Deber house president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I will um try not to repeat some of the
statistics you've already heard uh but
I'm here on behalf of my members and the
students we work with to support HB 655
uh we should be feeding as many of our
students in school who uh have need of
that kind of support because hungry kids
don't learn well um almost 40% of our
grand State children live in families
that experience some kind of food
insecurity at least from time to time
that may mean that at the end of a pay
period or at the end of a month the
family is running out of food and
there's not a lot left in the cupboard
so they may be to school hungry they may
not have much in their lunch
box so they are trying to do the hard
work of learning and getting along with
their peers behaving at school on a
nearly empty stomach that may be going
on for several days in a
row um my members often dig into their
own Pockets to stock their classrooms
with snacks uh you know approved by
whatever the district policy on snacks
is because they know that kids need
something in their bellies to you know
help them get through the long hours of
uh long division
um and I remember the debates on this
last year and hearing from some
legislators that they were surprised
there are Hunger kids in schools they
didn't believe that it could happen
because we do have to have access to a
hot meal for every student every day but
having access doesn't mean that the
student family can afford to pay for it
and that's where a lot of the problem
comes in families do not want lunch debt
they do not want the school district
coming after them for lunch debt and
students don't want to be taking a
different meal if that's what the school
district's policy is so that's where a
lot of the mismatch comes in
um I know personally of students who
have been told by their families you do
not get hot lunch you do not get in that
hot lunch line we can't afford it don't
go in line so they will send them with
whatever they can put in the lunch box
if it's just a package of uh peanut bar
crackers or you know a couple saltines
and that's your lunch if that's what's
in the cupboard that's what they might
come to school with for lunch that
day so they are making that decision
that they don't want to incur any more
debt because they can't afford it we
have got families who are doing the best
they can to keep the family you know in
the rented apartment meeting all their
other expenses so expanding the
eligibility from the current 185% to
300% of poverty would give that many
more of our Granite State families the
breathing room they need to support
their kids and when kids come to school
and stay in school with proper nutrition
every day they learn better um according
to feed the children in North Carolina
they did a study of kids who um were
food insecure and they found at the end
of the month when SNAP benefits run out
their test scores of those children
plummeted so this intermittent food
insecurity has an effect on learning
it's not just long-term
malnutrition
um overall kids who are food insecure
have lower math and test score this is
not just the same North Carolina study
they have higher rates of absenteeism
and tardiness at school and they are
less likely to graduate from high school
so HB 665 would take a big step to
helping more Grand State families help
the kids do better in school and help
our school districts have less
uncollected debt that they have to deal
with and taxpayers have to foot
um for all those reasons we support
passing HP 655 and uh that's what I have
to say thank you thank you are there any
questions represent papich thank you Mr
chair and thank you for testifying nice
seeing you again in different committee
rooms yes um I just wanted to quickly
ask you you described the scenario in
which a parent doesn't send doesn't give
the kid lunch and tells them not to get
school launches would that in your
personal opinion be a form of child
neglect if it happened again and again
and again yeah if it happens one day or
two days where do you draw that line I
mean if they forget to send them but ins
is that neglect or is that uh A hurried
morning I appreciate it thank you these
are yeah I know it's thank you further
questions represent fellows thank you I
I know it must change from one school to
another but do you have any sense of how
many kids fit into this category where
their their parents are are giving them
not not a sufficient meal and or telling
them and telling them that they can't
get in the lunch line I is any anecdotal
anything um I have not done a survey I'm
just I'm drawing on yeah yeah I do have
anol evidence from you my own experience
from people I've worked with um it's
going to be higher in some schools where
you have a greater percentage of
students or families that
are
living you know in poverty or or near
that poverty level but I really do not
have the numbers to go along with this
some of the people who were presenting
demographics earlier might have a better
sense of how many families we have
because they've looked more at the
Census Data um but yeah I just know from
having had
students um whose families were
struggling and you know sometimes they'd
be struggling for a couple days and then
you know it the check would come in and
it would be fine or you know Mom will
get extra hours that week or yeah that's
how families put it together sometimes
further questions from the committee not
seeing thank you very much y invite
hi Mr chairman my name is David Trumble
for the record from where I support this
bill for a few reasons uh last week or
maybe the week before you had several
food bills and there was a lot of
testimony about the value
of
um well-fed children just to add it
being the record again that they're
twice as likely to not repeat twice as
likely to not end up in special ed
reduce absenteeism twice as likely
to uh be suspended if not adequately fed
in four times increase in mental health
counseling and increased reading scores
in math and reading um I was struck in
the discussion um by the concern two
levels of concern first is the question
about the 185 versus
300% and why are we going up to that
extra amount and so I just wanted to
make a comparison between the EFA
program in the reduced meals program the
EFA program is set at
350% if you qualify once for an EFA you
qualify for Life your family is in that
program forever even if you have
multiple children in the qualify when
the oldest one is in you can stay in
until the youngest one graduates high
school this build doesn't do anything
like that it's it's going to be an
annual uh report based on
300% which is in line with how all other
income based programs are based so I
think this is clearly very fair there
should be no concerns about what about
that extra between 185 and 300 when
we're going to 350 for the EFA program
uh the second is the level of concern
about the quality of the meals and it's
been documented by several people that
there are federal guidelines that have
to be met
and that it could be made better there's
nothing that prevents New Hampshire from
encouraging local schools to increase
the quality of the meals at their
schools we could certainly do that you
already have the bill to have the local
farms to food program uh and many of the
local schools are having green houses
and things where their kids are growing
some of their own meals they have a
routinely uh a a vegetable and a fruit
where they hand it to each child and
they try it because it takes five or 10
times before a child will actually eat
something so they might not understand
what that vegetable or fruit is today
but over the course of attempts they get
to use it so there's a lot of regulation
on the quality of the content in this
bill just comparing it again to efas you
all know your education oversight
committee can't get any information on
it and yet we continue to fund it to
tens and tens of millions of dollars so
if we're willing to go to 350 fre FAS
where we see no need to have any
oversight or control on the content why
all of the sudden are we upset about
going to 300% for feeding children and
we already have strict regulations on
the guidelines the the last comparison
point is this is that every child would
be eligible to receive these meals
special Leed children or not we all know
that under the EFA special ed children
are not equally eligible because they
have to give away their rights many of
the EFA schools won't accept them you
remember the testimony about that at the
universal voucher hearing so I'm just
saying we spend
about the same amount of money for efas
as you're being asked to spend on this B
but we're concerned about the percentage
income we're concerned about the the
content we're concerned we're not even
concerned about the access under the FAA
over here it meets all of these tests
much better than that program does so
when you're thinking about this I hope
that people who are saying I don't know
if we think we can spend it will
remember how they're not concerned about
those things when it's an EA issue thank
you much
what yeah you
you
e
okay we're going to go ahead and start
this is the last bill for today it's HB
491 establishing a committee to study
alternative funding methods for public
education and how to reduce its Reliance
on local real estate property taxes I'd
like to welcome representative SPI
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman um nice
to sit in front of my
committee uh batting clean up here I
expect this to be a very brief hearing I
don't think that there's really a lot of
questions necessary to understand what
the bill does and I think that the
discussion about whether it's necessary
or or helpful uh probably should be
deferred until we get closer to March
20th this is uh a late Bill uh so the
purpose of the bill is to create a joint
committee with members of the house and
the
Senate not a commission no outside uh
interests just members of the
legislature balancing the two uh um
Chambers as well as uh uh offering a
cross-section of perspectives from uh
the ways and means that education
funding and finance committees now when
I put this LSR in uh the decision had
not been made yet and I hadn't heard of
it to divide uh the education committee
and so the the Advent of the education
funding committee does go a fair bit of
the way towards focusing on funding but
when we talk about funding and and I
think this has been the case with
virtually all of the bills we've heard
so far we're talking about
how does the state fund the cost of
education and assist districts and uh
make allowances for various uh uh
classifications of students and so on
and what I'm getting here to here of
course is the uh the sources of the
funds um we tend to deal with these
issues at
hoc and we may have an opportunity to
deal with these issues to some extent
here in Ed funding but most of our
funding bills are our early bills and uh
we then rely on our finance Brethren uh
to uh you know cook this all up in the
budget this is this is really intended
to be a vehicle for some more integrated
long-term thinking about what our
options are so the charge of course
comes in lines 11 to 13 under
duties funny how Ella um OS took my uh
statement and garbled a bit and turned
it around backwards so I'm going to read
it the way I would to assess the manner
in which the state now funds public
general education with a specific focus
on the impacts of overburdening the
local real property tax and make
recommendations for rebalancing and
changing available Revenue
sources now in the minds of some that
could
mean an income tax could mean the
general sales tax uh it could also mean
a lot of other things and and the
question is can we can we get all the
options on the table model them cost
them and say okay given the decisions
that were made in Ed funding and in uh
the and finance and the budget through
June what further thinking could this
group uh provide uh moving towards
November that would lay the foundation
for bills that could be introduced in
the second year of the session that
might rebalance those sources so if we
have a very very complicated array of s
sources there's a certain percentage
that uh is paid into the education trust
fund from the business profits tax the
business Enterprise tax there's even a
little tiny bit from the meals and rooms
tax meals and rooms of course is heavily
going to
Municipal um but there's a lot of money
there uh we rely heavily on um the
lottery commissions uh earnings and so
on if we know what we've decided to fund
then what's the best array what what's
the best balance to get those funds
from I'm not yet convinced that this
bill is
necessary I'll let you know as we get
closer to March 20th I think that
there's probably some justif justifiable
fears that a a committee like this could
go off in a uh you know an unfortunate
Direction and I suppose that might be
part of the discussion as well and I'm
perfectly open to any um you know
changes that might tighten up and focus
the uh the charge of the committee but I
think that we often find ourselves when
we sit on our legislative committees
reacting to specific bills and proposals
and these uh these more comprehensive
assessments don't generally get done in
that environment so that's why I've
brought the bill
forward any questions thank you very
much other questions from the committee
represent McGuire thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for taking my
question so the way this reads it would
be sort of
in okay with this um purpose if you were
to say fund the Department of Health and
Human Services with property tax and put
non-property tax into education but I'm
assuming that that's probably not your
intention is that correct what what a
great question it is not my intention to
just simply substitute no I don't think
it's any coincidence and I don't think
it's been lost on anybody uh that
Charlestown and Newport have been
offered by so many people testifying in
front of us the last couple of weeks as
examples of what's really wrong with the
way we raise uh funds for education so
we we all know the score generally
speaking we're asking real property to
do an awful
lot to fund municipal government almost
entirely to fund County government and
to fund
education and you know when we have
vehicles like the swep
tax to be very honest masquerading as a
state uh attacks but riding on the on
the
property we get very anomalous
results and so I cannot help myself but
to point out again that in Charlestown
where you have a real property mow rate
of 36.5 one or whatever exactly it is um
it just kills the town There's no
opportunity for growth there's no
opportunity to dig the town pull itself
s up by the bootstraps into economic
Prosperity so there are ways we can deal
with that there's actually a multitude
of potential Vehicles I've been a strong
advocate for reinstating fiscal capacity
disparity Aid because I think it's one
way to deal with if if the conclusion is
we don't want a an income tax or a sales
tax um we want to rely on the on the
real property tax then I think it
becomes important for the state to
figure out how to not kill certain parts
of the state because it works well for
other parts of the state so uh no it is
very very much my intention
to have a
discussion that finds alternative
sources to the real property tax and
Ames yeah it's on thank you um
your feeling
that we would gain from having a an
entity like this uh charged specifically
with trying
to break through the impath that we've
been struggling with for so long and not
been able to find our way through um
and so I welcome that um I think that I
know and we we all know that on the
table right now we've got a slew of
proposals that we're going to be looking
at in the next few
weeks um and maybe we'll make Headway
maybe we
won't I think if we uh make Headway then
we can set this aside and that's what
you said um I think if uh more likely
were
still struggling with this um this could
be helpful I'd want to be reassured that
it would
be um sort of Above The Fray a group of
people who really would look at this and
not be uh consumed by
partisanship um and um I think that
uh uh the appointing authority needs to
be specified in here I didn't see
any any language here about who
appoints um and
um the uh as you pointed out uh this was
written and
filed perhaps uh contemporaneously with
the decision to split the education
committee or just after or just before
uh in any event it refers to the
education committee and that has
addressed and
um and maybe the numbers need to be
changed a bit because the Ways and Means
Committee is a different role and
education funding committee has a
greater role than before at least than
education committee had before so we got
to figure those things out one member
from the finance committee gets us into
this partisan issue uh you know um
unless there's some person who really
everybody agrees is fantastic can can
deal with the with the substance of the
issue uh credibly um so yeah we need all
the help we can get and if we can have a
leading entity that digs into this
incredibly complicated problem um that
is uh plaguing us in our school
districts and our local municipalities
because uh you know it doesn't is not
working well right now now so the
property tax is carrying too much of a
burden so people are sort of kicking out
from that that problem and uh that's not
always healthy um so uh so let's hang on
to this and uh and do what we feel we
have to do in a few weeks um that's well
I I I share your sentiments and I'm
receptive to all the ideas app pointing
Authority the the representational
balance all those things to me are open
questions
I I I have a question just mulling over
uh what I think I hear here coming here
you know yeah we're going to be looking
at all the different bills that we have
and looking at fiscal capacity vers this
this this and this but is there
something else that's lacking in this
equation is the fact we're not looking
at the organization or structure or
governance of our education in this
state to know then how what the end
result is and how we're going to get
there rather than looking at here's
where it comes from but how's it going
to be used and how are we going to
ensure that we're using it in the most
cost efficient way so structure
organization and how we govern
governance I think are also part of that
equation if you're going to really come
out with an outcome that's going to be a
lasting
outcome they're all part of the same
same
Cosmos um and and separating them is
difficult but on the other hand if we uh
pose the question in a way that's too
diffuse then we don't end up focusing
and and getting a change in terms of the
impact on those communities that
struggle with exceptionally High real
property tax so while I agree with you
um I I I can't imagine how we conquer
the spending uh side of the equation uh
as a precondition to dealing with what
our you know Fair sources are U the
deliberate a session in my uh uh
charlestown's District which is Fall
Mountain occurred on Wednesday night we
uh finally after several years of
discussion uh uh authorized a budget
Committee in 2022 the budget committee
is just uh they were picking up stride
in the first year and this is their
third uh they came in with a budget that
was lower than the default rate a mere
$179,000 lower than what the school
board wanted and lo and behold at the
deliberative former School Board member
former uh business administrator for the
district got up and made a motion to
raise the budget to the school board's
level thoroughly undermining the efforts
of the budget committee I mean these
Dynamics are are in many ways so beyond
our
control but I I think that uh
the state has traditionally made a
qualitative judgment that local spending
and local funding should be tied
together and I think that's historically
why it's become the practice to rely on
on real estate but the real estate tax
at least in communities like the ones I
represent is just been given too heavy a
lift and I think that one of the things
that plagues the entire discussion of
education funding in the state of New
Hampshire is that when people say we
aren't adequately funding education or
we aren't providing enough funds for an
adequate education they're not saying
we're not spending
enough they're saying we don't like
where it's coming from we don't like the
pain it inflicts um in terms of our
property tax okay so where my district
has $23,800
average all-in cost per student that's
baking in everything special ed
transportation and so
on I don't think I haven't heard anybody
in my district say that $23,800 is
insufficient to fund the education so
this adequate education thing is really
code for
saying you know it's too much coming
from the the property tax and likewise
when people say the state isn't
assisting
they're saying the state isn't taking it
off the property tax and unfortunately
swept doesn't take it off the property
tax it adds it back on so these are
complex discussions that's why I'm
thinking a committee like this could be
helpful are the
questions paron me I think oh I I I saw
one here and one then represent fellows
after po papich thank you um so
it was my turn right because I jumped
the gun already once I don't want to I I
saw represent McGuire with his hand like
this I thought he had his hand up it's
pointing to
VI yeah okay
well thank you I I'm just trying not to
um your committee is supposed to only
look at
Revenue am I understanding this as you
thinking that the right way to fix our
school funding issues is to start by bu
budgeting Revenue based on the way we
are
spending I'm I'm going to try to
interpret your question because I'm not
totally certain I got it but it's
ordinarily the case in the legislature
that we ask the Ways and Means Committee
to do Revenue estimates they basically
bring a resolution to the floor with we
basically op adopt a resolution that
says here's what we believe we can work
with and then the finance committee goes
to work trying to allocate the spending
within that um you know that's fine but
the purpose of the committee is to think
more long-term conceptually about what
changes to the revenue either new
sources of revenue or or or changes of
allocation so this is I think perhaps
more an example of
saying what what is it that we think
that the state should provide and get
that nailed down and and get the budget
established and then say now given that
where's the most appropriate place to to
go find it and I just make a comment um
I think one of the deepest takeaways uh
for me out of two terms on the Ways and
Means Committee is um you can tax almost
anything to a degree but when you when
you tax it more and more you start to
really uh affect
behavior and and if you think about the
criticism of income taxes that's largely
what they often Center on uh does it
create um all kinds of incentives that
would be entirely different in a
completely free market situation but
that's true of every tax that's why
syntaxes are so popular right so that at
least some of the support for taxing uh
gaming and tobacco and even marijuana if
it was legalized is that notion that
when you tax something you discourage
it well we tax real estate more than we
tax anything else and when we do that
when we take that Beyond a reasonable
point maybe even to a breaking point we
affect Behavior in enormous ways that
are not well understood across the state
I don't see a lot of analysis coming out
of fiscal policy Institute about it I
don't see it really coming out of the
legislature and I think one of the
reasons you don't see that analysis is
because the impact is so vastly
different from one Community to another
that it's very difficult to generalize
across the state but the communities
that are okay with with the property tax
have to start to consider really
damaging effect to the communities that
situation represent fellows um I think
this is a great idea and I'm wondering
to make it a question if you were aware
that the last time anything like this
happened that I'm aware of was about 26
years ago and it was a commission that
the governor at the time put together
this was back when we got the Claremont
ruling just you know just before
2000 and I've I've read that report and
one of the things that struck me was
that the the models that they talked
about and the you know you know the
different characteristics of the
different Revenue sources is vastly
different today for some of them than it
was 20 years ago I think probably we
will see that the property tax will be
vastly different just because of the
whole change since the internet so I'm
just wonder if
you thinking that that might kind of be
a model for what you are thinking of
well I'm not aware of that study and I
appreciate your institutional uh
knowledge um I just know that in the
Horizon that I've been focusing on it I
Burton uh thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman I'm the
only one in this room that witnessed the
solution 40 years ago and we devised a
plan for what we should pay but we
didn't have the number we needed and so
when Governor sonunu said I'm not going
to put up
8% of the of of the school costs it all
fell apart the Supreme Court had agreed
with the formula we had devised it's a
bipartisan effort I talked to the woman
I co-chaired the committee with the
other day um this bill does
not get at what it should cost for an
education it just gets away it just gets
at what my question is Mr chairman um
this bill is not get at the cost of
Education it only gets at the way we
could spread the costs is that correct
that is correct and I I think we've been
blessed with a proliferation of bills
that give us an opportunity already to
focus on the spending side this gets at
the the sourcing side oh my me f the
question would you believe um I think
you're putting a cart after the horse we
need to decide on what we're going to
spend on education then figure out how
to pay for it and if you do you repeat
his like we did it'll
fail I I think you've said the same
thing that I did not you did no I'm oh
okay no I didn't to take I think that
the committee in coming weeks will be
deciding what the spending side looks
like and I think this gets to the
sourcing side thank you further
questions represent
kcom when you're talking spending side
are you talking about our spending side
as to how we're funding it or the
school's spending side as to what they
think think they should be spending for
an adequate
education good question glad to clarify
no I mean what I'm really speaking about
is the decisions that this committee and
the legislature is being asked to make
to expend State funds uh to assist those
districts I'm not talking about the
budget uh uh process within the
districts thanks can I have a followup
please
yes I like the idea of the study
committee would you would you consider
putting in here
also um the ability if we're going to be
looking at our funding and how we're
going to fund the
schools and we're going to Define I'm
assuming um through this sorry what the
adequate education um categories will be
right would you consider putting in the
the ability for us to also control some
of those expenses so that way when we're
looking at a Statewide what is an
adequate education cost on average we
have something that's pretty even
throughout the state and then any of the
extraordinary things that the school
districts want to buy or want to do or
things that they believe will help in
the education that that can be voted on
locally and then those people are
responsible for those um because I feel
strongly that we're kind of letting
people just have a blank check and then
expecting us to fund it and it's up to
the voters and and a lot of Voters in my
area think that throwing more money at
the school is going to give us better
results um and I'm just of the mindset
saying if we're going to do this maybe
we should be looking at controlling some
of those
costs so that we can buy better the
answer is yes to a degree I I think that
whenever you uh are talking about
sources and you say okay we're going to
tax this or we're going to allocate a
portion of that tax to the education
trust fund it's certainly fair game to
determine whether there are conditions
and limitations that would be coupled
with that to make it um palatable and I
mean palatable just in a judgmental uh
context but also as a political matter
so I I I yes to a degree I think that's
fair
game
e